salut le Fab ça va écoute ça va tu es
prêt pour pour ces demi-finales alors
attends j'ai appris un truc hier soir
et tu vas pouvoir donner ton avis
d'expert
je pense savoir de quoi ça parle vas-y
alors en fait il se trouve que tu as
remarqué qu'ils avaient des écouteurs et
des que les joueurs avaient des
écouteurs et des casques on en reparlera
un peu plus tard on demandera à la vie
aux gens et apparemment d'après ce que
j'ai vu alors j'ai pas retrouvé le
passage exact mais c'est quand même un
truc je fais confiance ça avait beaucoup
de commentaires et c'était c'était sur
Reddit mais apparemment les joueurs sont
obligés d'écouter de la musique pendant
qu'il lorsqu'il joue parce que c'est
enfin moi je pense que c'est pas mal
mais faudrait que ce soit le choix de
ton adversaire est obligé d'écouter ce
qu'il veut que tu écoutes ouais alors ça
c'est c'est exact c'était une idée de
Vlad en plus à l'époque
alors moi j'étais étonné dans le sens où
les parties sont homologuées et ça
paraissait dans les oreilles tiens ouais
ça me paraissait étonnant et pour moi ça
peut un peu expliquer le tweet aussi le
le
tilt un peu de Douda ou quoi quand tu
écoutes de la musique tu es un peu donc
tu vois je reviendrai un peu sur ce que
j'ai dit sur sur Jean-Christophe j'étais
pas au courant du du truc en fait
moi j'écoute de la musique en général
mais ouais mais
enfin genre tu as des gens que ça
déconcentre en fait d'écouter de la
musique enfin moi
tu mets enfin tu m'obligerais pas enfin
ça me gênerait mais c'est d'ailleurs
interdit en tournant en fait donc là ils
font l'inverse là c'est obligé mais
après c'est ce que j'ai lu écoute euh
non bah c'est spécial enfin de te faire
un tournoi officiel ou tu es obligé
d'écouter de la musique
j'étais étonné j'imagine c'est parce
qu'il devait avoir du bruit autour et
qu'ils veulent pas que les joueurs
l'entendent et donc ils obligent à
écouter de la musique écoute c'est
pourquoi pas tu leur mets un casque qui
coupe le bruit et puis c'est tout et tu
entends rien tu mets un casque de
chantier là normalement tu
vois bah écoute c'est peut-être une
nouveauté
qui qui va qui va faire avancer les les
échecs
on t'oblige à écouter de la musique
pendant pendant les parties donc je mets
bien avancé comme ça
enfin voilà c'est une nouveauté ça n'a
jamais existé c'est une information que
j'ai chiné mais j'ai pas retrouvé
l'extrait ils en parle il parle d'une
interview à caméra on parle
mais alors est-ce que tu as le droit
est-ce que tu écoutes vraiment ce que tu
veux est-ce que tu as le droit de tu
vois non j'avais vu un tweet de toute
façon de chaise comme qui disait à votre
avis qu'est-ce qui coûte Maka avec une
vidéo ou quoi il a dit sur la tête donc
c'est peut-être juste c'était vraiment
premier degré tu vois mais je crois
ouais mais alors après je cherche l'info
mais c'est vrai que ça expliquerait
pourquoi ils ont écart ce qui écouteurs
et les écouteurs qui sont reliés à autre
chose j'en sais rien moi peut-être que
le casque il y a d'autres infos dedans
j'en sais rien il y a des casques ils
sont maintenant c'est devenu classique
quoi
en tout cas le fond de la question c'est
ce que tu non moi je pense pas que ce
soit une bonne chose forcément de la
musique que tu leur laisses le droit de
le faire pourquoi pas en fait mais te
forcer à écouter des trucs non enfin
mais vu que le tournoi homologué fit ça
veut dire que la feed approuve le fait
de forcer l'écoute de la musique si si
ça vérifié mais du coup c'est pour ça
que ça compte pour le lot sinon non en
fait tu écoutes rien tu tiennes comptera
pas pour toi et clairement ça t'avantage
si comme carotte a l'habitude de jouer
en écoutant de la musique que quelqu'un
qui a l'habitude de jouer sans musique
enfin genre un avantage énorme à
certains joueurs ouais ouais c'est le
toi tu es pas des concentré
officiel mais c'est pas qu'on avait
forcé c'est qu'il y avait une une
Technoparade à côté ou une je sais pas
quoi et des chars qui passaient et tout
et ça faisait trembler les vitres il y a
du son à fond ça s'est arrêté bon
j'étais très bien je m'en foutais en
fait mais l'adversaire il était pas bien
quoi
voilà tu choisis ta musique
pour toi pas celle de l'adversaire
malheureusement ouais mais justement
nous on va améliorer la règle t'inquiète
ah ça ce serait beau par contre tu mets
un peu de Patrick Bruel ça va pas être
bien en face
automatique par abandon d'ailleurs
tu fais chialer quoi
alors on attend le début des parties je
crois qu'ils ont encore décalé le début
Fab ah ouais non parce que c'était pas
assez tard évidemment alors non en fait
ils ont commencé Niall Sarine contre
Aniche guéri en match principal cette
fois-ci nous comme on suit la caméra
c'est ce que tout le monde aurait fait
c'est sûr que tu as Barça-Real et à côté
tu as
tu as je sais pas quoi Rio Vallecano
riron qui va-t-on mettre en prime time
moi je me demande rien je sais pas
pourquoi ils ont fait partir en premier
très franchement
bah écoute on va un peu regarder leur
partie en attendant l'autre enfin je
suis un petit peu étonné
si ça se fait arnaquer ou pas
et du coup ils ont carrément changé les
câbles les caméras de joueurs ouais
c'est
[Musique]
ouais c'est fait tu as ça à chaque fois
je suis dépassé par le design parce que
c'est je mets un truc en place et ben en
me disant c'est quand même très logique
tu vois là je me suis quand même dans la
logique et en fait je me fais dépasser
donc c'est Gary qui a les blancs
j'ai mis côté noir pour que la caméra
parce qu'en fait ils ont fait tourner la
caméra de sauver guéri
ouais ils ont changé de ouais
écoute non écoute c'est bien moi j'aime
bien c'est ces petits ces petits
décalages de temps et tout ça laisse un
petit peu la surprise Fabien
complètement chaque jour on est là
bah t'as pas le côté où tu sais ce qui
va se passer c'était tout le temps dans
le dans les spectative et
tu vois c'est du direct
tu sais pas qui va jouer quand ou il y a
des petits des petits travelcam là toi
tu vois pas ouais c'est magnifique là ce
qui est en train de faire
le ouais ouais c'est beau on a vu un
geste technique du cameraman fabien a
assez exceptionnel
il a fait quoi il a fait des retours il
a fait des petits aller-retours tu sais
un peu comme dans le sketch des Inconnus
un peu comme dans le 7 inconnus comment
il s'appelait ce sketch déjà
c'est celui où ils font une blague sur
les
Power Rangers
nous sommes les gentils
de Dorothée c'est vrai en plus bah oui
ils arrivent pas du tout avec des armes
normal tiens écoute ça
aux échecs dans les conditions des
règles qu'on va mettre
marrant cette règle de musique j'ai
vraiment cherché quand ça me paraît
tellement lunaire que je suis vraiment
allé chercher et tout j'ai pas réussi à
trouver l'extrait mais bon le truc c'est
que sur le poste que j'ai lu ta personne
qui disait tu vois en mode
non arrête de raconter n'importe quoi
genre les mecs qui discutaient quoi
faire qu'est-ce que tu en penses
qu'est-ce qu'il écoute
[Musique]
qui arrive il est en train de mettre la
musique sur ses oreilles Naka qui sourit
qui met le casque
je pense ah oui mais 5,5
oui évidemment c'est faim
quoi
tu peux quand même tourner tu as des
cases aussi pour toi donc
on a parlé sur son stream après c'est
game avant-hier il disait qu'ils étaient
obligés oui
il a bien confirmé club je suis quand
même hyper étonné que le que le tournoi
soit homologué fille franchement
il y a beaucoup de choses qui font que
c'est chelou mais là la musique
obligatoire enfin c'est la musique c'est
le dernier truc
la cerise quoi
la belle cerise c'est pas la petite sœur
ça me paraît alors que que le tournoi
soit comme ça que ce soit ses règles ça
ça me dérange absolument pas c'est
organisé un tournoi tu fais absolument
ce que tu veux après que la fille
homologue ça comme condition de jeu
normal pour que ça compte pour le vélo
ça me paraît
je sais pas c'est à dire que c'est les
deux mains tu fais un truc tu as
quelqu'un qui fait de la tronçonneuse à
côté de toi et ça va être un standard
normal de tournoi obligatoire d'ailleurs
obligatoire
ce que vous en pensez vous dans le chat
mais je trouve ça étonnant que que le
tournoi compte pour les points et l'eau
avec de telles conditions de jeux
je trouve pas que ce soit des conditions
de jeu qui qui qui soit un standard
tu me diras il y a des matchs de foot
qui se passent sur des terrains
complètement pourris et ça compte
oui mais on t'oblige pas il trouve qu'il
est pourri parce qu'il est pourri parce
que c'est comme ça il a plu eu trop de
soleil
au bout d'un moment il y a quand même
des limites quoi là en fait c'est pas si
jamais tu es dans un endroit et puis il
se trouve que dans la salle à côté il y
a un concert et que tu entends un peu du
bruit bon bah tu as rien demandé mais on
sait comme ça mais en fait tu es obligé
le concert à côté quoi limite non
toujours pas de concert ouais c'est ça
c'est très étonnant
flaque d'eau sur le terrain de foot on
jouera pas
ouais c'est pas que tu l'autorise c'est
que tu l'obliges ouais c'est c'est
exactement je suis tout à fait d'accord
c'est pour éviter qu'on leur souffle les
coups ouais enfin je veux bien mais bon
dans ces cas-là mais juste pas de
casques du tout en fait il y aura pas de
coup soufflé à rien en fait tu les
contrôles tu vas pas le
Garrett de partout et puis ça va bien
quoi le Bel quoi
je suis un peu faim voilà je suis étonné
de cette règle et comme je l'ai apprise
cette nuit et du coup ouais pour moi ça
dédouane un peu le truc de de Douda
franchement
on peut pas demander en demander non
plus trop joueur Fabien je trouve non
mais non ne pas faire de trois deux ça
va c'est pas non trop quoi
le bruit bon bah ça c'est autre chose
non ça te saoule 3-0 tu es de la musique
dans les oreilles tu vas retourner jouer
la 4e partie faire un bout d'un moment
je veux bien comprendre quoi
non c'est pas du tout l'histoire avec
Douda mais je comprends que ça ça pousse
un peu
musique que tu aimes pas sur ta playlist
qui tombe en plus je pense que tu peux
pas faire comme tu es chez toi c'est à
dire changer les musiques comme tu as
envie tu vois parce que moi je mettrai
du Booba du machin du Jul mais bon on va
au moins tu as peut-être envie de tu
vois
un petit Patrick Sébastien pour pour
égayer
un petit bonhomme en mousse quoi
j'étais très heureux je me suis remis un
peu les la chanson du dimanche ça
faisait hyper longtemps
c'est bon
ça nous rajeunit pas exactement
que ça joue une énième espagnol
ouais donc la fameuse anti berlinoise
avec cette version moderne avec dessin
rapide le Douda avait jeu qu'on a qu'à
alors bon il y avait eu pas tout à fait
ça
c'était pas très bien passé pour
Jean-Christophe
pour liquider la tension au centre après
on va te dire c'est léger léger plus
pour les blancs mais bon 3 fois rien ça
vient juste que tu es plus content
d'avoir
de cayans des deux que le client C6
parce que ici s'il a un peu dominé bah
parle dans ces trois
alors que les deux bah il va pouvoir
aller verser 4 ou vers F1 G3 voilà bon
je te rassure tous les gens du chat bon
c'est égal en fait là ça changerait pas
grand chose
pourtant mais là il nous manque la barre
là enfin en même temps je commande
désolé excuse-moi je l'avais je l'avais
enlevé pour pour les blancs ça je peux
vraiment le dire
a été plus à l'aise là
je m'étais un peu des pincettes dans ce
que je disais les gens vont mieux voilà
il a quand même la barre la 25 je le
vois
elle reste quand même un peu à
l'intérieur du 5
E
[Musique]
il reviendra plus fort il sabre il
repart en décès de galoper ailleurs il a
tout à fait raison
il a tout à fait raison c'est bien joué
ça serait beau qu'il écoute la chanson
du dimanche
si j'avais le pouvoir d'achat
[Musique]
c'est beau et très heureux
d'achat quoi
être content parce qu'il a des objets
avec fil il a les
pièces une tente que je suis là enfin il
est très bien quoi
il est au top ouais des chemises ananas
aussi pour lui donc il est très très
bien quoi
Alexandre de 4%
ce serait beau en fait tu le tournoi en
écoutant ça tu es très heureux quoi
ouais mais en fait tu es très avantageux
si tu écoutes cette chanson
c'est plutôt bien joué de la part de
Wesley
je vois pas écouter des musiques
amusantes mais je savais pas quoi et toi
tu écoutes quoi moi honnêtement je
savais pas quoi écouter pour jouer
que je puisse changer là je crois que tu
peux pas changer quoi ta playlist enfin
ça je serai un peu perdue quoi puis 15 +
2 c'est pas une bonne en fait en blitz
ça me dérangerait pas pendant 15 + 2 ça
me gênerait
ouais
bon après bah je pense c'est mieux
d'écouter des trucs
j'aime bien le pouvoir d'achat j'aime
bien musique française à la con j'aime
bien genre année 80 bon je peux écouter
des trucs comme ça quoi
du coccinelle
où es-tu non mais je sais pas enfin
parce qu'en fait ça dépend tellement de
mon humeur des positions et tout que moi
ça me gênerait réellement en fait
il écoute l'Insee
[Musique]
tu peux aussi t'écouter des trucs comme
ça un peu de piano un peu de
en tout cas ça me gênerait réellement
enfin très franchement
pour ça ça me ferait perdre du niveau de
jeu pour
pour cette cadence pour du public non
parce que c'est plus à l'intuition tu
l'as acheté quoi mais là pour calculer
ça me gênerait
mais je pense que je suis pas le seul
ouais mais c'est bizarre des fois en
fait je j'arrive à être focus à plus
trop écouter ce qui se passe autour
mais bon je peux comprendre que ça gêne
ça colle avec lui et
non mais c'est des belles règles en fait
en tout cas ça fait parler
des films en fait à l'intérieur de la
partie tu vas faire un résumé du film je
fais un résumé pour bien montrer que tu
as bien suivi mais si t'as pas bien
suivi le film c'est Rivers le et on te
pose des questions elle a commencé à
fêter le personnage qu'est-ce que tu
vois
l'intrigue ton avis va se passer quoi
dans le prochain épisode
et si tu réussis pas ouais en fait tu as
perdu la partie ce qui t'obligerait
vraiment à regarder le film voilà
je pense que quand on est au serait très
fort à ça ouais il a un grand
entraînement
et vous vous écoutez de la musique dans
le chat quand vous jouez aux échecs ou
pas
mais moi pour le coup vous sur Internet
j'en écoute quasiment mais bon tu vois
enfin je prends pas ça super au sérieux
quoi
si je fais un tournoi normal c'est vrai
même pas idée quoi même si on m'autorise
moi j'aime bien aussi mais j'aime bien
pouvoir en changer à ma guise
je peux pas dire à l'avance ce que
c'est que du Magic System
[Musique]
le Dimanche à Bamako c'est le jour mais
c'est qui eux
[Musique]
la chanson du dimanche par exemple c'est
pas mal mais je pense que pour c'est en
blitz ça va mais je pense qu'en rapide
comme je te dis plus de temps ça me
dévoile trop envie de faire
un peu quoi tu es bien quand même hein
et tout tu es très bien quoi
[Musique]
ça se passe pas trop mal je veux dire on
est parti
il y a pas de problème quoi
il est plutôt bien
mais il fait un bon début de compétition
le chat
et argenté ce chat
[Musique]
je pense qu'ils ronronne à fond non ce
chat le chat doit
vous ne voyez pas à l'écran
malheureusement il y a pas le voyez pas
le chat je pense c'est tout à fait le
type de chat le chat sur la photo de
profil de Wesley qui ronronne quand tu
vas le toucher
c'est ce type de chat je pense après
avec l'oreille aussi
enfin je pense après je sais pas hein
non on connaît pas ce chat
mais
j'aimerais bien en fait
j'aime bien les animaux ah j'ai une
petite engie aujourd'hui
il y avait ces
gens qui l'accompagnaient qui étaient au
restaurant quand elle était allongée
elle dormait enfin c'est très bien
ouais après je me disais des têtes un
peu frustré enfin tu vois je veux dire
oui c'est concentré encore en train de
bouffer personne m'apportait enfin
l'état allongé les gens manger sur la
table et elle dormait avec les yeux en
fait elle est allongé avec les yeux
ouverts
un peu à chaque fois pour pour les
chiens quoi
il faudrait lui donner un petit peu
de trois petits trucs qui traînent quoi
[Musique]
un petit morceau de viande là regarde et
il a glissé de la fourchette au hasard
c'était pas terrible parce que les
blancs des fonds attention
la même trois fois maintenant
tu peux le rattaquer une troisième fois
aussi pour lui dire moi aussi j'attaque
ok mais défend mais bon pas génial enfin
on voit le fouet fin qui tire la gueule
quoi
il y a beaucoup de pions sur sa couleur
ne pion à 4 ça peut être une cible
contrairement au pion à 5 qui est bien
soutenu avec la chaîne de pion donc
plutôt mieux il y a des cases un peu
faibles sur case noire aussi de l'autre
côté après un cavalier 5 pour arriver
donc ouais écoutez Caro un peu en danger
plutôt moins bien
après bon c'est dans ses cordes de
défendre ce genre de truc mais
tu es pas contente de démarrer ton match
comme ça bon après il y a quand même 8
parties tu as le temps de
remonter même si tu perds
toutes les cases noires c'est un peu
pénible aussi
en fait il est mieux parce que il peut
contourner faire des choses notamment
c'est en Russie imagine tu arrives un
peu les pièces dans la finale tu vas
l'attaquer les pions adverse alors que
le fouet fin il est en mode plot alors
il peut défendre ses pions j'insiste à
la place de la dame mais c'est tout il
aura que un rôle défensif au mieux mais
on imagine mal devenir intéressant alors
la finale cavalier contre fou elle
serait vraiment bien pour les Noirs si
je vais pas entre le KS c'est 5 contre
le fouet fin alors que si tu joues un
cavalier B3 contre un fou B7 c'est quand
même les noirs qui sont mieux
en fait toute pièce restante contre le
fou F1 et meilleur n'importe quelle
pièce mineur
et le fou Bessat était meilleur que
toutes les autres pièces quoi
bon voilà donc c'est vrai que pour
l'instant il faut baisser de ne rien
mais il a un potentiel et qui pas en
mode
utopie c'est juste assez simple de faire
facilite aussi donc il s'améliore
parc les blancs tu vois tes pions ils
sont fixés quoi le pion B5 va pas dire
ouais ben je le pousse aussi je la
meilleure structure fixée
est-ce que tu as changé une paire de
cavaliers tu remets l'autre c'est un peu
la maso il te dit un peu comme quand il
fait le Maroc aussi j'échange toutes les
pièces et je gagne contre le foot et
toujours très heureux ah bah tiens j'ai
encore changé une pièce
après bon faut juste faire gaffe que à
la fin le fouet fin se retrouve pas en
dessin qui soit pas si mal quand même un
peu pas le laisser s'activer si
facilement
mais oui kfd ça je trouve ça pas mal de
toute façon tu aimes bien avoir un
cadeau danger de plus la voir je voulais
prendre une fois pour attirer la dalle
et revenir après pour lui regagner un
temps mais bon après est-ce que ça
suffit j'en sais rien non mais on verra
mais oui tu reviens c'est ça que tu fais
pousser vite tu fais FC tu mets après le
fou aussi
OK et puis tu réfléchis quoi
tu pousses en HK tu prends de l'espace
partout quoi
4 là ça a fixé une grosse pièce donc
[Musique]
donc oui
là c'est mieux pour les noirs
aux échecs de toute l'histoire du tennis
et en fait tu changes un pion de toi qui
était pas faible donc
qui reste à une cible long terme donc
c'est pas un échange dans l'intérêt des
noirs
une amélioration pour les blancs la
disparition de ses pions au mieux vaut
ne pas le faire
cette stat
s
je sais qui joue hein j'ai déjà parlé
qui dit que ça a beaucoup qui a la
progresser au rugby les échecs en fait
je crois les échecs en fait c'est beau
les échecs c'est bien pour tout sauf
pour les échecs
[Musique]
placier étonnant
au contact des salles battles
comment dire
c'est pas mal de faire un peu des échecs
après c'est juste à haute dose que tu
vois enfin on a trop d'exemples on se
dit qu'en fait c'est nocif quoi mais
la petite dose c'est sûr que ça des
vertus
et que ça joue plaisant quoi qu'il en
soit
[Musique]
a passé de tout au Madrid
je tape la connerie on va voir si une
info de chat ou pas
je suis très heureux de jouer contre
Rafa ça existe de pas à Madrid
je pense pas je pense que c'est une info
distance Bourgue et arrêtez au cas où
il y a pas de photo
effectivement mais le mec il a un
drapeau croate et
bon déjà il a pas joué depuis 2018
par contre dans les tennisman connu qui
jouent il y a le numéro mondial qui joue
aux échecs
il aime bien
il a gagné l'US Open
mais le revers là un peu
un peu bombé
le couverture de terrain également
bon service ticket non mais il est assez
complet en fait
il est assez complet c'est explosif
écoute si continue comme ça il peut
juste bien dominer pendant un moment
quoi après il y a rune aussi là qui joue
pas mal
ouais moins bien je pense mais oui oui
c'est une nouvelle génération de toute
façon donc ils sont failles ils sont
forts quand même là les jeunes
là je sais pas enfin en fait
ils vont prendre le pouvoir par la force
des choses fait je sais pas tu vois
enfin
des choses ils sont forcément plus forts
en fait moi je pense que
fondamentalement en fait le sport
devient plus fort dans toutes les
disciplines donc ils seront forcément
voilà à 19 ans ce que fallait que race
c'est vraiment très très impressionnant
oui mais Nadal c'était impression aussi
etc enfin ouais mais ils sont encore
plus fort que le ça a progressé que par
rapport à tout le monde
mais ils ont juste rien fait et ils ont
fait battre par des papis à plat de
couture quoi et bon là les papiers sont
trop vieux maintenant mais en fait j'en
sais rien c'est ça je veux dire
forcément un jour mieux que tous les
autres obligatoires
toujours comme ça
ça le sera toujours
ce que je veux dire là je sais pas
comment ça se fait mais il est vraiment
placé la barre hyper haute quoi
quand il était là il va faire travailler
à gagner à 3 fois 3 grands chefs
[Musique]
un peu au milieu là qui était pas
terrible et je mets juste en fait ça
dure taper sur le système de rien gagné
au bout d'un moment en fait je fais tous
les efforts tu gagnes jamais en fait un
peu plus mais moi je pense pas qu'ils
ont dans le chat je pense pas qu'ils
égaleront les records mais je pense que
comme on progresse tout le temps donc
tout que infini ils seront plus forts
parce que ben
[Musique]
ils ont progressé parce qu'ils étaient
là en même temps ils se jouaient les uns
les autres ils se sont arrachés pour se
dépasser
et peut-être que là t'auras pas l'alter
ego enfin c'était plus qu'un alter ego
c'était du coup trois mais
qu'il y a une conjoncture qui a fait que
en fait ça les a poussé à fond vraiment
se déplacer un truc de ouf et je sais
pas en fait tu vois enfin faut aussi un
contact pour ça arrivera forcément un
jour de toute façon
mais oui
on peut pas trop dire
après de toute façon les méthodes
d'entraînement superfictionne le
matériel c'est perfectionne etc donc
ouais rien que le matériel en fait
il renvoie juste quand on regarde tes
années 80 que de toute façon ça va plus
vite maintenant ou quoi mais c'est juste
pas les mêmes raquettes et c'est pas
pareil en fait il a raison regarde quand
tu quand tu revois s'embrasse agacites
etc on pensait que c'était 100 prasser
agression pensait vraiment que c'était
on verrait jamais ça enfin qu'on verrait
jamais ça et puis
et puis il y a eu encore mis il y a
toujours mieux en fait
mais c'est sûr que la marche de
progression elle est de comme aux échecs
d'ailleurs elle est de plus en plus un
film
puis bon tu apprends de ceux qui ont été
avant toi aussi bah oui
alors encore plus
pour les échecs par exemple un truc
comme ça les échecs oui là c'est
vraiment
la coupe du monde de foot ça commence
quand bientôt dans moins de 20 jours 18
jours je peux pas le 20 je crois ou le
ça arrive vite c'est très bien
[Musique]
bon je te cache pas que je suis pas
emballé par cette coupe du monde mais
bon j'ai quand même un peu suivre c'est
sûr
non non mais je suis pas je veux écouter
ça mériterait mais bon ok c'est comme ça
mais je suis quand même pas emballé
soit par le lieu la date etc mais bon
peu importe et
[Musique]
un favori bon on va pas la France
qui donc le Brésil va être pas mal
l'Espagne Brésil - Espagne et peut-être
Argentine pour la dernière de Messi qui
va peut-être essayer de tout faire
on peut dommage qu'il a fait Wesley là
il pleutrit le truc donc il peut rien
lui arriver mais je vois pas comment il
va créer une menace
après peut la jouer longtemps oui mais
[Musique]
avec le kappa à côté ça peut mériter
pandef pour jouer Sox attention quand
même mais attends mais c'est ça qui
parle de repêcher l'Italie pour les
mettre à la place de je sais pas qui ah
bah oui il faudrait pourtant
je suis pas sûr qu'il faut le faire une
semaine avant la Russie au hasard ouais
mais bon voilà ils ont déjà été banne 9
mais à la place
avec le Danemark qui joue bien je sais
pas moi j'ai lu des trucs Danemark
favoris
en 55 ans de quoi il disait
le problème la France c'est que il y a
beaucoup de problèmes là tout d'un coup
l'important tu as les meilleurs
individualités du monde et ouais mais tu
as plein déjà tu as plus de milieu tu as
plus grandi ta plus Pogba donc tout d'un
coup ça te fait un trou bah c'est
sérieusement en fait tu peux être choix
béni et enfin qu'il assure toute la
Coupe du monde et qu'il prenne toute la
responsabilité pour les tout seul tu
vois alors que c'était plus un joueur
qui va être très bon qui est déjà bon
mais normalement il doit être accompagné
quoi ça doit pas être le taulier déjà
donc déjà voilà puis il va être tout
seul tu vas lui mettre du rabiot avec ou
du je sais pas qui mais c'est pas mal
oui mais c'est pas il y a pas la musique
qui aimerait bien avoir du rabiot en
milieu de terrain
oui il va des équipes comme l'Iran quoi
oui ils aimerait bien mais le Brésil il
s'en foutent je peux te le dire
et puis après la défense on est un peu
dans la merde
et voilà alors après devant ok devant
des pas mal devant on est pas mal parce
que tu as quand même pas payé
Benzema
Griezmann qui hard reprend un peu la
forme
bien dans ta commane
Dembélé ta Giroud bon moi je sais pas je
le prends évidemment mais bon
tu as une coucou voilà en fait tu as que
des bons attaquants
en fait c'est pas du tout ce qui a fait
d'échange qu'à présent de jouer
l'attaque il veut pas prendre de but et
normalement d'ailleurs tu gagnes pas une
coupe du monde en jouant l'attaque mais
de toute façon qu'est-ce que faire
d'autre ta défense prend l'eau tu as pas
de milieu bon bah je sais pas mais tes
attaquants et puis je sais pas si il est
marqué plus que l'autre quoi enfin on
peut rien faire d'autre
Varane il est tout le temps blessé là je
sais pas s'il va pouvoir enfin il va le
sélectionner mais je sais pas dans quel
état il va être bon nul
et
donc c'est chaud enfin tu vois tu as pas
de gage de sécurité ni derrière ni au
milieu
mais je crois qu'il va quand même le
prendre parce qu'il ça peut être une
blessure à long terme il va te blesser
de 3 semaines donc tu veux le mettre
titulaire dès le début ça va être chaud
et
on se tape pas Varane
moi je te rassure je vais pas suivre
donc je
te pose quelques questions
quoi enfin moi je prends des infos parce
que c'est dans une semaine de fin de
semaine je suis pas trop le foot et tout
j'en profite quoi
j'en profite pour un peu savoir les
forces en présence
bah la France j'y crois pas
et tu penses Brésil aux Argentine alors
Amérique du Sud cette année ouais
Brésil ils ont quoi maintenant un peu en
joueur star
[Musique]
c'est toujours Neymar mais
non ils ont une belle
plus ou moins assez complet en fait ils
ont fini
ils sont un peu relou ils sont pas mal
il y a les codes de passeports
[Musique]
en plus c'est jean-marivé dans le game
de coupe du monde sur coup ah si ça
arrivait avec le Brésil non Brésil je
pense mais il y a longtemps
encore je réfléchis mais
[Musique]
58 62 je pense
mais
[Musique]
je peux ça ils ont gagné la première
donc
je suis d'accord enfin moi j'avais ça en
tête mais
du monde Coupe d'Europe à la fois
dans une Madonna non non ils ont fait
deux finales ils avaient gagné 86 ils
ont perdu 90 mais
je suis plutôt Barça je suis plutôt
Barça en fait et le Portugal
en fait
la Grèce 2004 qui aurait pu prédire
avant de toute façon nous ici je pense
on sera pour le Brésil non
le pays
moi
je m'en fous
les matchs on l'appelle machin alors
cricore quand ça on dirait de Sao Paulo
quoi cricore qui nous donne un peu
l'ambiance quoi
la France je crois qu'on arrive à bout
de souffle
mais on a enfin je sais pas comment dire
c'est même pas que les blessures qui me
font peur quoi c'est que je sens plus la
force collective qu'il y a eu un moment
ou juste une sentais que peut-être rien
pouvait arriver tu es bien tu étais
tranquille là
et en plus son 5 3 2 j'y crois pas
je déteste le schéma qui veut mettre en
place parce que j'ai l'impression de
bons joueurs de couloir sa coman ou
Dembélé justement tu peux plus les
mettre et Mbappé tu peux le décaler
enfin tu peux vraiment mettre des mecs
sur les côtés alors que avec le 5 3 2 tu
te retrouves avec jouer clos à droite
bon ok ta théorie à gauche tu es bien
quoi mais
c'est tout ça c'est un schéma pour tenir
Hernandez
tu mets trois défenseurs centraux ce qui
était pas ta forme ça t'enlève d'autres
enfin je sais pas je suis pas du tout
dans le truc
bon après écoute si jamais
[Musique]
15 minutes je pense qu'il est très bien
c'est ça en fait je pense en fait on va
plus jamais pouvoir l'inviter pour rien
en fait c'est fini enfin Mathieu il a
fermé en fait waouh bon il a dû
comprendre avec moi que ça là il pouvait
pas
cornet
va te faire [ __ ] avec ton humble enfin
sans moi quoi
si c'est pour me reprendre 15 coups de
prépa
sans façon et bah qu'il est bien là
aujourd'hui ou pas j'ai eu tout à
l'heure
j'ai gagné machin très heureux pour
contre un 2005 mais oui très bien il m'a
dit ça me motive à fond là de faire les
vidéos mais oui faut pas être un 2004
j'ai dit hyper motivé je suis très très
motivé là
bon c'est cool mais où on peut quelqu'un
a c'est ça sa partie si quelqu'un a un
lien
ostrian budosliga ouais parce que j'ai
pas trouvé hier c'était un lien
j'aimerais bien voir ça partie ça
m'intéresse je sais pas
je vais fouiller en même temps ouais
dis-moi ça m'intéresse limite plus en
fait
quelle équipe qui
a une grosse équipe en fait
son équipe 2003
il a défoncé
bon il est un peu bougé les pièces il a
mis un dessin qui l'a repris de
l'attaqué le pion E7 l'autre l'a bougé
de la prix des structures de merde bon
il a gagné très facilement quoi puis
finalement tu as des pions de merde tu
as des pièces de merde voilà oui le
gagner sans effort quoi et que c'était
il gagne quoi il gagne encore un virgule
4,5
[Musique]
un peu plus loin de deux
c'est fini quoi enfin trois parties plus
8 ça remonte quoi
dans les grosses équipes en fait
un joueur de grosse équipe
en fait ils sont fous quoi
[Musique]
je regarde un peu les équipes
aujourd'hui ils ont pas un match facile
mais bon ils mettent déjà de zéro
beaucoup plus fort que les autres mais
genre c'est pas fait sur le papier enfin
des gros favoris mais voilà il y a qui
bon ça c'est une équipe de con complet
1800 et tout la compo de l'équipe de
Baki là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et peut-être que ils ont des mecs sur le
banc j'en sais rien en fait
ça en cours de partie quand même c'est
génial il y a une équipe il y a une
équipe croate enfin c'est qui votre
chaîne mais croître 100% croate quoi ils
Venza reach antiber kitch Lionel livage
le frère ah mais ils sont dangereux en
fait c'est la Croatie
on est là
[Musique]
du coup en fait les grosses équipes
c'est les Croates les Allemands et bon
bah l'équipe de Baki au dessus mais bon
faudra voir les scorer contre sur un
match tu sais jamais mais ils sont bien
c'est beau
championnat par 6 joueurs
chaque pays un peu ses règles si joueur
8 joueurs on sait jamais
et donc hier qui est déjà au dernier ah
mais ils ont joué
d'ailleurs tu vois qui a gagné
il jouait hier
et aujourd'hui je joue pas le robot
parce qu'il joue un peu des plots quoi
ils avaient mis ici au repos mais bon on
peut le mettre quand ils veulent quoi
mais quand ils ont fait pour pas gagner
en fait bah c'est chaud contre les
crottes enfin du coup Maxime il a fini
contre sa reach il avait les Noirs bon
c'est pas facile même si 70 aux deux
paramètres les blancs elle a fini le
compte birkitch en petite
contreperformance mais l'autre et 26-10
c'est pas gagné d'avance après il y a
livaïque qui a battu l'exenco ça c'est
une contrepert
et l'équipe des Allemands ils avaient
galéré il a gagné trois demi deux et
demi vous avez gagné donc ok bah écoute
c'est ça ça va jouer entre ces équipes
là c'est clair toutes les autres sont
trop en dessous
mais bon aujourd'hui bah écoute ils sont
pas mal enfin ils mènent de un mais en
fait
ouais ils vont gagner à l'arrache je
pense
là
parce qu'il y a Jules qui a perdu avec
les blancs en train de 2004 donc là
forcément c'est un peu dedans par un
magazine mais premier il a un pion de
plus contre espinko donc il peut gagner
enfin tu vois faut encore conclure mais
ça pourrait faire de deux avec cinco il
joue mais bon un tout peut se passer et
juste ok naïditch est en train de Carry
il est gagnant complètement
ils ont déjà trois points donc en gros
faut pas qu'il fasse zéro sur deux avec
les roses coffres
et pas de raison mais bon enfin j'en
sais rien
bref voilà pour les nouvelles de
points quoi
bah oui oui on s'en fout qu'on veut
juste que lui il gagne des points
c'est vrai en plus
pourquoi tu parles en fait
nous on veut que Bakugan
tout que l'inverse ah bah oui enfin
c'est qui t'a choisi oui que l'équipe
perd et que Baky gagne en fait
c'est pas le FC
en tout cas
qui aime VIP de la compétition
c'est des belles nouvelles que tu nous
apportes là
j'étais même pas au courant de
l'existence de cette ligue tu vas
peut-être y jouer très bientôt aussi tu
es très heureux quoi
j'ai peu trop de contacts
[Musique]
je me doutais bien que ça existait il y
a des conditions dans chaque pays mais
j'en ai jamais entendu parler donc je
pensais pas que ça pouvait être aussi
fort je pensais que c'était un truc avec
des joueurs locaux et puis voilà
c'est pas
plus ça dépend les règles parce que
justement en Suisse alors qu'un étranger
donc on était genre locaux qui jouent
mais là en fait bon tu as les équipes
nationales de Croatie qui se déplacent
et tout quoi
c'est sympa comme délire en vrai ouais
au moins ton équipe s'entend bien enfin
c'est pas mal quoi
ce serait beau en fait si on joue en
ligue portugaise
sur deux il en reste une partie pour
prendre 7 8 points et l'eau là c'est
bien
de la musique pendant les parties en
Autriche je crois que ça se trouve
fréquence une petite pause là 5 minutes
6 minutes
[Musique]
donc Fab ça a repris
un peu en avant cette fois-ci mais c'est
guérisseur
[Musique]
un peu pris de cours parce qu'en fait ça
à 18h05 moi d'après ce que j'avais
compris
le design pour
[Musique]
ils ont laissé les deux autres cartes
finales en fait
attends ouais ouais mais attends ça
j'avais enlevé c'est juste que attends
jusqu'en ayant fait on est tout le temps
pris de cours quoi c'est ce que je
disais en fait on est tout le temps à
contre-pied du j'adore en fait
attends attends je suis en train de tout
remettre bien
en fait on passe notre vie à être à
contre-pied
ouais le classement attends ouais
j'arrive pas à retrouver comment le
bon c'est pas très grave pour moi c'est
juste que c'est facile à enlever c'est
juste
oui enfin ce serait pas là ça serait
mieux mais en soi c'est la vie quoi
ça me rend fou
bah ça rime un peu comme prévu en
difficulté
[Musique]
on avait dit ce sera une
opposition de style
et
ce qui va arriver à l'arnaquer ou pas
bon dans la première non mais il y a
cette partie
[Musique]
bon ça s'invite enfin disons
quoi ça doit être encore théorique
je suis vraiment plus ou moins on a fait
pour battre Ding va être très fort
numéro 3 sur Internet
en plus peut-être
ou même en rapide d'habitude je pense
que rapide il est très très bon
spécialiste internet joueur spécialisé
du coup il est extrêmement dangereux
mais ça joue pas là faut que je m'en
viens en fait là c'est
ça va jouer t'inquiète pas Hugo
mais bientôt
bon dans le sens opposition de style
pour répondre à la galette c'est que
fait guéri plus fort a priori
c'était un peu comme séviant qui est
complètement dominé le match contre
Sarine dans le jeu il est souvent
l'avantage et il concluait jamais
et donc c'est en ça aux questions de
style parce que guéri on imaginait
qu'elle avait un peu le scénario donc
mieux jouer être bien mais est-ce que
lui il allait arriver à conclure ou se
prendre des pots de bananes ou les
éviter voilà ça ça va jouer à ça au
réalisme en fait
les formes vous le voyez pas fabriquer
ça me surprend toujours
[Musique]
ça dépend de beaucoup de choses là dans
ces conditions là je le sens moins
favoris contre guéri mais après c'est du
55 ans
ça a une joue en vrai ou pas du tout il
joue en vrai aussi mais je crois qu'il
bloque un peu à 26 60 dans 26 70 là
depuis un moment il arrive pas
le dû faire un truc correct enfin la
dernière fois je l'avais vu en vrai
d'approcher des 18 ans je sais pas
exactement mais je peux vous faire une
petite recherche je vais vous dire ça
né en 2004 donc oui bah il est proche de
18 ans il les a eu d'ailleurs
il venait d'avoir 18 ans
c'était ça dans la chanson
[Musique]
de progression encore ben pas si sûr
parce que ça fait quand même longtemps
qu'il est là comme c'est comme ils font
beaucoup beaucoup d'échecs quand ils
sont jeunes ils ont parfois moins de
marge de progression que que d'autres
joueurs qui sont un peu qui ont un peu
plus à aller chercher encore
du coup moins fort que Google
je sais pas la galette il faut voir
ça dépend des tournois des mesures aussi
après attention
bon là il a l'air en ce moment moins
fort
un jour n'est pas forcément celle du
lendemain c'est compliqué de savoir
dépend de il y a beaucoup de facteurs
qui jouent dans les échecs
musique pas musique
blog je peux pas toujours savoir
la vérité d'un jour n'est pas celle du
lendemain
on peut pas vraiment savoir
pour devenir encore meilleur ou pas bah
ouais on lui souhaite enfin c'est ce qui
vise en tout cas d'être encore plus fort
mais il est perfectible dans ce qu'on
voit certaines finales
il est très perfectible encore à les
raisins donc c'est pas mal enfin ce qui
fait bien il le fait hyper bien et il y
a des petits points faibles ici ou là
qui pourraient corriger enfin qui doit
travailler dessus et je suis sûr il le
fait et donc
[Musique]
il peut vraiment faire mieux
2022 je crois qu'il revient en fait les
tours sur internet ça le saoule en fait
en gros il veut plus faire en fait on a
fait beaucoup plus jeune et là c'est
vrai que moi je pense qu'il a raison en
fait
bon après il peut en faire de temps en
temps ça mange pas de pain pire tu es
éliminer tes éliminer tu comprends plus
fort que toi tant pis
[Musique]
en quelque sorte
bon je peux comprendre aussi
une petite overdose qui s'est arrêtée
d'un coup sec quoi de les faire
et voilà après je sais pas quand est-ce
qu'il rejoue ça il joue très très peu
quand même les
en fait
non mais je parle même pas sur internet
en réel en fait c'est à dire que là il a
fait une pause énorme cette année pour
se préparer pour les candidats
bon bah repose il a fait un peu la
tournée
où il a été très bon d'ailleurs et le
temps allons après la fin de 960 à Saint
Louis et puis depuis plus de nouvelles
depuis septembre ça fait déjà deux mois
donc en gros là sur quasiment un an il a
eu
elle est jolie candidats
les trucs aux États-Unis et basta il a
joué de moi en fait après il a peut-être
aussi vu la progression de Maxime à
folghize
ouais
qui tombe pas et oui il est peut-être
obligé d'aller en chercher quelques-uns
est-ce que il y a une baisse du vélo
d'un joueur non tu peux tu peux ne pas
jouer pendant 50 ans si tu veux ton élo
de bouge pas
tu es de retour
c'est pas comme au tennis ou tu perds
tes points pas défendu là tu es bien
bon après je sais pas trop quoi penser
de ça enfin je pense qu'on va d'évaluer
petit à petit mais bon au cas où tu
t'embêtes personne en fait tu joues plus
on enlève de la liste on devrait plus
puisses un jour tu reviens tu reviens
bon
ah le problème c'est plus pour l'intérêt
de la saison
que du coup les joueurs sont pas du tout
je pense qu'on peut lutter contre ça
enfin en fait on s'en fout quelque part
du vélo du mec qui joue pas le seul truc
c'est quand tu piques une place
qualificative à quelqu'un d'autre quand
il y a des places qui est éducatives au
vélo ah bah oui là ça devient pénible et
en fait on te permet de ne pas jouer
d'être qualifier quand même là ça va pas
donc faudrait que chaque tournoi qui met
des places qualificatives au hello
disent bon bah dans la saison ou dans
les deux dernières années il faut jouer
50 parties ou sans ou 25 enfin je sais
pas après peu importe ils choisissent
leur nombre mais qu'on te laisse pas
être inactif
en fait c'est très très simple de lutter
contre ça enfin c'est tout tu mets ça
comme règle et puis sinon en général le
vélo il est pas qualificatif ou pas
qualificatif enfin la plupart du temps
c'est des Open en fait les mecs
s'inscrivent pas et les tournois au
niveau qui sont sur un vide bah de toute
façon si tu joues plus on pense plus à
toi donc on va pas t'inviter donc
quelques parts ça change pas grand chose
le seul truc ça va changer c'est ça
c'est pour étendre à calife genre c'est
comme si tu avais un gros hello et que
tu dis ah bah tiens je joue pas pendant
deux ans pour me qualifier au candidat
grâce à ça après ça le problème du
coefficient du hello que tous les
tournois est la même valeur le
classement et l'eau il a il a des gros
problèmes je suis en train de voir qu'il
y a Valero qui vient de tweet
alors il a vu l'ouverture de Baki
et en fait il te dit c'est trop subtil
pour moi
j'aime bien les subtilités dans les
ouvertures mais celle-là est trop
profonde pour moi c'est Baki donc
en fait il a fait 4C 5 F3 e6d4 bouf qui
prend des cartes à 6 il a fait H3 en
fait aujourd'hui
issue quoi je suis pas en capacité de
comprendre quoi
qu'il faudra qu'il regarde
simply backy hein je lui écris
un coup de merde
[Musique]
ou alors il a réfuté cette sicilienne
aussi s'assiste je pense que quand Baki
joue un coup il réfute une ouverture
quoi
dans ce cas avec qui joue une nouveauté
même deux jours après les mecs sont pas
capables de la comprendre encore donc
c'est aussi des cassis ça je crois
ment
et que ça doit être un coup d'ordi parce
que je vois wemmerdam qu'il a joué en
mai 2022 et tari en août
donc ça va être un truc lilas ou j'en
sais rien en fait
mais aux Olympiades Taris a joué et
Vermeer d'armes il a joué en Bundesliga
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est un coup un peu
étonnant je vais pas
comprendre est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui
jouent ça ah d'accord ils se mettent à
ça
je crois je crois Fab
je vais me faire mon avis mais j'ai une
petite idée de éventuellement pourquoi
ou pourquoi pas
mais non
réfuté mais c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
OK
[Musique]
ça confirme ta pensée là ce que tu es en
train de regarder
mais
après je sais pas moi
en tout cas c'est subtil ouais
il expliquera dans le retour de 1700
enfin si on est en capacité de
comprendre
ça joue là ça arrive
bon j'ai une tentative d'explication
et alors c'est fort
par contre là tu demandes beaucoup mais
en gros sur H3 les Noirs ils ont
un coup logique c'est cavalier F6 et il
veut jouer fou des trois donc après il
aurait joué fou des trois sur cabalifié
celui de A6 et sur kics il prend il veut
juste structure
ou pas ça c'est un autre débat mais avec
le pion raciste parce que tu fais qui
est ici ce qui prend B3 qui sont à 7 ou
à 6 ma foi c'est peut-être même pire en
assise parce que tu as pas de fois 6 et
ok bon voilà et sur l'autre coup
d'attente que le mec a joué c'est verdam
C7 mais qu'il a joué fou des trois et en
fait tu peux dire ok je crois ça va
vraiment rien
parce que en fait tu veux jouer des
trois directs c'est-à-dire c'est censé
être un des coups principaux sur un 6
fous des trois mais il y a une ligne un
peu principale c'est fou c'est 5 dessus
attaque avec ton cavalier tu fais quel
B3 il fait x 7 ou X7 et donc il va se
fois 7 tu fais de la musique 4 pour
attaquer G7 et il peut faire calife 6
parce que dame prend le 7 tours J8 etc
et en fait
quand tu prends G7
donc tu empêches déjà cette ligne donc
peut-être il peut te faire camifooter 5
et better partir en E7 mais déjà télé
une fois 7 etc donc tu dois éliminer des
lignes tu rends l'autre normal qu'elle
est fils pas forcément génial tu fais tu
joues une structure en noir et
voilà ça va être un coup pour jouer donc
je pense pas que ça affûte la ligne en
toi mais il y a des idées
là mais c'est ce que je peux en
comprendre rapidement comme ça c'est pas
fait pour suivre l'échiquier à ça c'est
juste que on discute entre nous pendant
que les parties se jouent on voit un peu
les parties là ça a l'air bien pour ça
et qui va arriver en C7
il faut faire tout à 7 sur ks7 c'est ça
on voit la joie qui monte de toute façon
et sur la jauge aussi
qui est de grande utilité
ça te fait un petit peu mal
s échéant
compliqué pour
pour NiAl pour pour guéri pardon dans ce
match contre NiAl ok du coup
une belle réaction
et Naka c'est pas parti je pensais
partir et peut-être on regarde jusqu'à
la fin là on ira après bien sûr
ok c'est de jouer tour à 7 et donc on se
donne à tous c'est ça voilà
une jolie variante d'ailleurs sur
C8 E6
je me serais dit t'en prends B6 cool
s'il veut prendre en SESSAD je prends
deux fois je mets deux tours sur la 8e
j'ai gagné puis bastaque enfin en fait
non après en partie longue j'aurais
probablement vu qu'il est 17 mais en
blitz je me serais raté là
je prends je m'en fous enfin
presque sérieux ou je réfléchis vraiment
je sais pas je peux je peux quand même
voir enfin c'est pas impossible mais
il y a sérieux un blitz où je mets la
chanson du dimanche et que je suis là
comme ça je me le prends ça c'est 1000%
c'est un peu moins je sais pas je peux
pas dire si j'aurais ou pas c'est des
coups qui sont dans mon style mais c'est
que quand je suis en forme
que quand je suis hyper concentré sinon
c'est dans mon style
j'aime bien chercher des petites
tactiques comme ça
absolument sans réfléchir ah bah toi tu
cliques juste ouais la musique je chante
bon bah voilà sérieusement non si je
clique
il fixe
ça prend forme c'est terminé
c'est beau
c'est beau ça relance le match
immédiatement enfin bon attends faut
encore conclure mais bon ça a l'air
assez simple quand même
on est assez confiant pour le genre
indien mais qui
m'écrit
les trésors
pas une belle partie mais les poules le
Punto fait plage
pour un tel tu sais il a des standards
beaucoup plus élevés que toi c'est
Fabien des fois que tu lui dises enfin
tu lui demandes
[Musique]
tu sais Kevin j'ai toujours pensé qu'un
tel comme monté sa riche ne pourrait pas
comprendre ce coup
bah non mais il a raison
il peut aussi juste rentrer dans un truc
où il comprend pas trop ce que tu veux
faire et
puis trop tard quoi
en tout cas c'est bien quoi ça le
remonte ah je suis très heureux du coup
en fait
c'est magnifique
si tu veux te déclouer tu as toujours
les trucs comme ça ou tu savais ça que
quand tu as un double clouage
tu te barres tu te barres en fait c'est
les trucs sont pas protégés ah tu manges
je te mange
tu manges là
je sais pas si je savais mais je veux
dire que ça marche toujours enfin ça
marche
je m'en vais je te bouffe de l'autre
côté je me le suis déjà pris plusieurs
fois ça m'a saoulé maintenant j'ai
remarqué ça marche souvent ce truc là
genre tu fais le cloche que dans un sens
mais tu sais que double cloison jamais
en fait là je crois
c'est chiant
toi tu me laisses de double prise ça je
me suis déjà pris genre tu es là tu es
très heureux si oui il est cloué mon jeu
encore de l'autre côté là il pourra
vraiment plus jamais bouger ah merde il
part
d'autant plus
que je t'apprends depuis
tu vas revenir en tournoi tu vas être
deux fois plus fort
[Musique]
on va des règles de partout quoi c'est
magnifique je sais plus que ça bon les
fous c'était les plus impressionnants
mais
[Musique]
on est devant un autre règle hier
c'est trop hein
sur sur deux semaines de commentaires
retenir la règle des fous déjà c'est
bien
j'ai le Tiken si il connaît pas bah oui
mais bon bah fallait être là pour le 960
les gars quoi bah oui parce qu'il y
avait la règle des fous
vous pensez être 360 je connais pas les
échecs 360
positions
[Musique]
mais sinon oui bonjour j'aime bien
j'aime bien jouer j'aime bien suivre un
peu comme ça
juste pour jouer qu'autre chose en fait
j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait plus de
tournoi et pour jouer
une partie du jeu d'échec 960 du coup
exactement
complexe
[Musique]
on est tellement tellement fait des
échecs toute notre vie normaux que la
vision là en fait on est matrixé on peut
peut-être apprendre à quelqu'un direct
avec l'autre jeu j'en sais rien ce que
ça fait en fait
je sais pas c'est bien si c'est mal j'ai
juste jamais essayé mais peut-être que
ce serait une bonne méthode
débrouille-toi tu apprends pas de
théorie fais jouer tes pièces de manière
active
pourquoi pas en fait enfin ça peut être
bien mais
en tout cas en tout cas voilà donc moi
ça me
ça m'apporte rien de spécial à regarder
mais c'est plaisant et puis peur de
belle partie et après à jouer c'est cool
parce que justement ça enlève la théorie
et cette force à réfléchir dès le début
donc tu joues vraiment aux échecs quoi
voilà t'es pas là à répéter tes trucs
quoi de prendre une prépa
voilà
c'est pour ça que j'aime bien mais bon
pas après inventer peut-être plus de
trucs sur une nouvelle vision quoi
il traîne la Sarine pour conclure
il y a tellement une belle position
après ça va il a beaucoup de temps un
peu réfléchir maintenant pourquoi pas
bon il peut juste prendre B6
[Musique]
j'ai jamais joué mais peut-être que ça
je sais pas
je fais progresser en tout cas ça c'est
sûr
ce qui est déjà pas mal
évidemment
faut pas le dire
c'est tellement compliqué
il y a quoi en plus
comment il y a quoi comme pièce en plus
au Shogun c'est pas les mêmes pièces en
fait
japonais
j'ai joué une sorte de d'échec bizarre
comme ça c'est un truc où il y a une
rivière au milieu le roi dans un palais
ça c'est le genre ok peut-être voilà ça
j'ai joué très peu 4,5 parties
intéressantes pour le coup mais voilà
donc tu vois je sais pas trop le shoguer
ce que c'est si c'est un peu similaire à
ça en fait quelque part
non non le show qui met le shogun en
fait tu vois des positions
vraiment j'ai un tout petit peu joué
mais en fait quand tu regardes les
parties pro je te jure sur les positions
dans lesquelles ils abandonnent bon
pourquoi tu abandonnes en fait
le truc c'est que les pièces
ne disparaissent jamais enfin quand tu
manges une pièce la récupère tu la
reposes comme dans le Crazy house elle
revient sa vie enfin c'est toi c'est tu
la remets en vie comme tu veux et donc
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que ça se
finit toujours avec toutes les pièces
sur l'échiquier avec des attaques de
maths des deux côtés c'est que du calcul
de fou en fait et c'est que du calcul de
fou et enfin l'idée enfin c'est un peu
comme si tu jouais que des parties à
recoposer tout le temps aux échecs que
tu gagnes tout le temps toutes les
pièces sur les chéquiers et que c'était
systématiquement au tempo le premier qui
m'a fait en gros mais hyper compliqué
d'accord donc en fait
il abandonne oui bon 14 tu vois mais en
fait c'est que c'est que ça en fait
position oui bon
et donc c'est pour ça que le mec enfin
des meilleurs joueurs de shoguy il s'est
un peu mis aux échecs du genre 2004 non
et genre 2004 non c'est parce que je
fais le jeu est très simple
pour lui alors que les meilleurs joueurs
d'échec qui se mettent au shoguy bon tu
te prends des tactiques tout le temps
partout tu vois rien tu es en fait c'est
l'avantage mais du coup je mets
t'imagine peut-être en fait c'était
biberonné au Shogi tu passes aux échecs
à 14-15 ans peut-être que tu es juste
hyper fort en fait
la stratégie aux échecs
jamais de tactique tu t'en fous tu fais
ta tactique à ton autre jeu et après tu
tiens viens calculer un peu ça
mais tu sais j'avais lu un truc qui
disait que si tu étais sur une si tu né
dans une planète où les joueurs ils
jouaient les meilleurs joueurs du monde
étaient tous à 3500 Hello
en fait une finie t'aurait plus de
chance de jouer à 3500 enfin je sais
plus j'avais lu un truc comme ça mais je
sais plus comment c'était formulé
exactement mais dans l'idée en fait tu
serais tirer vers l'eau en fait du
niveau des autres et tu aurais beaucoup
plus de chance de t'en approcher j'ai
pas à quel point c'est vrai
match d'échec shoeing ouais ouais
peut-être que déjà qu'il a gagné
j'imagine
ouais mais je pense que le mec aux
échecs auraient des chances de lui
prendre une nul alors que lui au chogui
il prendrait 1000 0 quoi
lui c'est un des meilleurs pour calculer
aux échecs
[Musique]
ça me fait un peu penser à Dragon Ball
en fait Maxime c'est un genre de Krilin
pour eux quoi
un peu du sel tu es un peu du vagin bon
ben
je pense qu'il est très fort pour des
lambdas
Simon ils sont disques ouais c'est ça
en fait c'est un Krilin quoi
en plus c'est vrai c'est ça le pire non
mais c'est vrai c'est marrant j'aime
bien les comparaison quoi c'est
il est là il se bat et
quoi
c'est genre de Broly quoi bon
c'est qui aime chat
il est vraiment nul c'est la croix là il
a cicatrice
[Musique]
c'est une époque peut-être ils sont là
meilleurs personnages de Dragon Ball Fab
moi j'aime bien son Goku mais c'était
pas le meilleur tu vois peut-être que
Vegeta il est plus perso préféré quoi
original quoi
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi Gohan
tout d'un coup il y a l'idée d'être
chercheur en fait
il y a des prometteurs
j'ai une anecdote fantastique aussi sur
[Musique]
sur Dragon Ball en fait
il va gagner là
il devait tuer Vegeta en fait enfin
Vegeta il devait pas il devait mourir
en fait les fans étaient très énervés
ils ont écrit ils ont dit oui enfin on
va casser la gueule si je te fais chier
et du coup bon ils ont sué ils ont été
obligés de laisser en vie
c'est dommage pour lui il est pas sur le
bon il te faut la tour en des deux et le
Cavaillon
enfin ils partagent leur photo il se
cache
issu en fait les mangas
de quoi sur le sur le déroulement de la
suite du truc avec les fans ils ont trop
peur de
mecs qui leur disent non pas de se faire
menacer enfin il ressort de menaces de
mort enfin bon c'est
on se disait peut-être la jauge très
bien pour ça mais bon c'est je sais pas
c'est clair mais c'était quoi cette
encore une antibiérinoise enfin ça
pourrait vu la tête de la position mais
ça peut être une italienne ça peut être
plein de choses
je mets les caméras
ok c'est à peu près symétrique une fois
de plus hein mais bon il a le four il
presse un peu F2
bon je passe
mais bon
quand même
moi je suis capable tellement de perdre
ça en trois coups avec les Blancs c'est
terrible quand je vous
j'arrive jamais tu peux me dire le début
ce qu'il a choisi
en fait tout à l'heure j'ai jetais un
œil pour voir si ça avait commencé et
j'avais vu le début de la partie sur
sur ça que je t'ai pas pressé d'aller
voir en fait
donc ils se font un truc thématique je
trouve avec les blancs avec les Noirs
l'un à l'autre
ouais
[Musique]
vous devez faire un stream sur ce
problème en fait c'est que moi j'ai du
mal à lire les noms des pièces en fait
ça me gêne
parce qu'en fait les pièces en fait
c'est des le nom est écrit en japonais
dessus
en plus les pièces changent prête à des
généraux d'argent d'or je sais pas trop
ce qu'il foutent et du coup
tu dois tu galères déjà à comprendre ce
qui est écrit sur la pièce en fait de
qui t'a en fait
je sais pas comment le truc bouge bon
sérieusement pendant un mois
ok pas mal comme ça non non
je fais des ex un peu des exos et tout
et puis après je fais quelques parties
mais après ouais je joue en belette un
joueur de belette on peut l'aide j'étais
quand même je cliquais en fait regarde
que toi connard
ça ça avance d'une case et c'est très
chiant les pions ce qu'ils avancent tout
droit
[Musique]
mais après c'est pas très grave ce que
tu peux pas reposer un pion sur une
colonne tu as déjà un pion
tu peux pas avoir de pions sur la même
colonne donc en fait si tu gagnes un
pion et puis tu as tout tes pions ben tu
peux pas le poser en fait avant que tu
dois vraiment gagner
tu le gagnes mais tu peux pas l'utiliser
quoi
il met l'autre la plus ouais mais il va
te le bouffer avec d'autres pièces c'est
assez faible pion ça avance que d'une
case quoi
il est dans ta main
je te prends un fou et après je me
repose j'aurai trois fous et toi seul
exactement ah bah voilà une petite nulle
magnifique
un peu vite ok il prend le 4 il était
peut-être pas obligé mais bon il a
failli la fin et
donc la petite nulle donc il y en a
partout dans les deux matchs
qu'est-ce qu'on se fait on fait la
petite pause
qui était champion de Shogun c'était le
fils de Damien
ah d'accord ok le fils de Damien est
super fort au gui c'est un des meilleurs
joueurs français je pense qu'il était
top 5 voire même top 3 français j'espère
pas dire de bêtises je suis pas
spécialiste en France mais c'est un des
tous meilleurs joueurs de Shogi
européen ok mais je savais pas ok ok
mais très gros joueur de chevaux
mais bon ok beaucoup trop simple
excusez-moi non mais pas l'air d'y
porter un grand intérêt aujourd'hui
mais très fort au Shogun très gros
joueur de Shogun
il a fait ses études au Japon exactement
je le connais un tout petit peu enfin
quand il était petit je l'ai un peu vu
je le connais pas très bien je connais
plus d'Amir et ça sert Mélissa que mais
ça fait tellement Milan que je l'ai plus
vu pour moi en fait c'est encore un
petit enfant quoi
maintenant il doit avoir quasi 30 ans 30
ans peut-être
bien 20 ans je l'ai pas vu mais gros
genre de chose qui
ça te fait un peu suer quand même
si je suis fort et qu'il a fait sa vie
un peu au Japon le permet de visiter le
nouveau pays une nouvelle culture tu
vois c'est cool quoi après je crois pas
qu'il est pas joueur professionnel joggy
juste très fort quoi
c'est peut-être difficile de trouver de
ce jeu je sais pas je pense qu'il faut
vraiment pas dans les fautes dans les
meilleurs japonais je pense pas dans les
meilleurs européens les meilleurs
européens je pense c'était pas très
sympa c'était pas très fort tu es très
fort quand même tu dois être très très
loin du niveau main au Japon
ok bon ben écoute tu vas faire cette
petite pause on se retrouve ça reprend
quand à 19h on vient vers 18h55 19h un
peu de musique quoi on souffle un peu
voilà voilà parfait à tout de suite et
si jamais ça on arrive ouais on est là
on m'appelle tu m'écris tu me dis
nickel allez à toute
[Musique]
on est de retour attends j'ai mal clic
allez objet bien clic
les joueurs sont pas là mais attends
c'était Naka et so je fais ce qu'on fait
ce qu'on fait du nacasse l'eau est-ce
qu'on va voir je sais pas comment faire
je sais pas quelle heure ça reprend je
sais rien en fait femme
puis on avisera pour la prochaine fois
[Musique]
encore pour 10 minutes à temps du coup
j'aime pas trop faire de partir en fait
ça fait plaisir de dire
imagine domine pas
tout le temps de faire en fait
c'est plus une valeur sûre
en plus
de monde
c'est une victoire une victoire chacun
pourquoi systématiquement il y a jobava
qui me propose des partis en fait
moi en fait
moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] en fait enfin
laisse-moi
dessin vraiment très intéressant comme
joueur je dois la fenêtre était
pas mal on peut regarder mes parties
d'hier soir si tu veux
mais ce qui t'a
vas-y
mais j'arrive plus j'arrive plus à
égaliser dans le système de Londres en
fait je me prends toujours ce truc là il
s'est trompé mais j'arrive pas à m'en
sortir dans dans cette ligne là en fait
je sais pas si tu connais je connais
rien du tout ça je fais ça ça
je le retrouve toujours mal
l'autre jour on se final à la con là
un peu faible
du coup peut-être que je fasse 5 C3 je
me rappelle plus comment ça marche en
fait et à 6 ok moi j'en profite hein
dans un cadre des 5 OK
ça a l'air d'aller ok bon j'en ai
profité
très bien
[Musique]
défoncé mais ce qui t'a en fait
ouais c'est là c'est magnifique
ment il va souffrir voilà c'est fait
quoi c'est pris au sein dans la tranche
il est monté
[Musique]
[Rires]
la tour ça me saoulait il me fait chier
attaquer la tour j'ai vu dame 5 ça E2
lui bon je sais pas il attaque peut-être
le pion enfin je suis un peu d'arnaque
quand même
mais en fait il y en a une que je
voulais revoir spécifiquement
ouais en fait c'est la dernière en fait
il m'a fait un truc que je connaissais
pas
donc ça c'est réputé comme étant très
mauvais
il m'a fait ça ça et
j'ai pas vu
mais bon
plus grand chose et du coup je me suis
retrouvé un peu en sueur
après une position qui était marrante
regarde cette position m'a fait très
plaisir j'étais très heureux
ils vivent leur vie
c'est un peu déçu ce que j'ai dû
changer ils sont tous partis
là-bas et aussi venu ici bon
mourir au combat mais pour ouais mais
après quand ils sont retrouvés là au
centre ça va ça va
pour cela septième rangée magnifique
ah les autres ils jouent
pourquoi
je l'aimais pas en caméra parce que ça
on va regarder l'autre partie mais assez
garé avec les Blancs
[Musique]
ça fait partie des possibilités
c'est comme un beau joueur de pierre
moi j'ai jamais compris la pierre
j'ai un bon livre à suggérer ouais non
mais c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé
j'ai trouvé que c'était bien ça
s'appelle the perfect pire que moderne
de moscalinko
et en fait pourquoi j'ai lu ce livre
c'est juste que je veux dans le même
club que lui quand j'étais à Barcelone
donc je vivais là-bas et je lui ai
acheté le livre la main enfin bon enfin
vas-y bah j'ai que ça à [ __ ] la
semaine en fait j'étais à Barcelone je
jouais tous les dimanches par équipe et
la semaine j'aurai rien à faire donc
j'ai lu le livre mais en fait c'est pas
un livre de théorie théorie c'est juste
qu'il te fait des chapitres selon les
setups des blancs donc genre attaque au
tricher
F3 qui est C3 les attaques avec feu 3
dames des deux F3 machin les G3 les
trucs bon et tout le monde est parti
dessus qui commence
du blanc machin bon il tourne des
parties tu es parti à lui tu vois petite
idée tu peux peut-être faire si tu veux
peut-être faire ça enfin la plupart du
temps c'est un peu de la merde tu mets
l'ordi il est pas content mais il
t'explique le sens du de ce qu'il veut
faire de quand tu places les pièces
qu'est-ce que tu fais tu comprends les
plans les idées et après tu te démerdes
mais c'est pas mal en fait c'est un des
meilleurs livres que j'ai trouvé pour
une ouverture en fait
pour pour la commencer la plupart du
temps c'est que des ventes théoriques en
fait bah tu apprends par cœur n'hésitez
pas ce que tu fais donc c'est de la
merde
là au moins
tu comprends les enjeux etc et c'est
bien
c'est très heureux en fait je te dis
bien donc en fait je le recommande pour
commencer après évidemment tu peux quand
même analyser etc et puis il y a
d'autres livres maintenant par exemple
il y a des trucs que j'aime répertoire
là c'est énorme livre des pavés de
théories de marine donc le grand être
roumain qui a fait un truc dessus
ça peut être vraiment complémente avec
tous les livres de comment il s'appelle
Tiger moderne de Tiger hilar-personne
au vu des hyper optimiste il se laisse
attaquer comme un fou mais il kiffe donc
lui il te parle de l'hippopotame ou quoi
il est très heureux etc mais lui
l'analyse il analyse bien il montre
aussi c'est parti enfin c'est tous les
livres peut être complémentaires les uns
les autres mais en tout cas celui que
j'ai le préféré c'est celui de
moscalenko
et donc globalement ce que je dois dire
de la pire que c'est que c'est une
ouverture pour jouer pour le gain avec
les Noirs tu joues pas ça si tu veux
juste faire nul en fait en gros tu crées
vite un déséquilibre et quelque part tu
agites le drapeau
pour le taureau quoi le drapeau rouge du
le fait foncer dans le tape pour qu'il
vienne essayer de te défoncer
parce que c'est étonnant parce que
finalement de jouer la pire qu'avec les
Noirs tu joues plus pour le gain quelque
part que si tu fais juste tes f3g3 avec
les Blancs
parce que justement quand tu fais qu'il
est 3G 3 est noir vont se retenir ils
vont faire des cinq machins et pas
prendre trop de risques quoi
alors qu'en fait il faut dire c'est la
même j'attends de plus mais en fait le
fait qu'ils aient les blancs ils ont
quand même envie de te défoncer comme là
tu vois ce qui fait gris
il joue pas un truc pleutre quoi il te
fait grand rock il a envoyé la dame
là-bas il s'est doublé les pions en
échange etc bon peut-être c'est très
bien ou pas mais que les Noirs
franchement tu peux facilement contrer
quoi c'est pas
et donc dernier détail à dire pour la
pire qu'un ce que je pense c'est que
c'est une ouverture prenons à jouer à
partir d'un certain niveau ou au moins
un certain niveau d'expérience parce que
c'est une ouverture avec une structure
très modulable tu peux jouer la personne
avec eux 5 tu veux la personne c'est 5
les blancs peuvent se laisser prendre en
D4 peut fermer le dessin qu'à chaque
fois donc là déjà on parle de plein de
structures différentes ça peut
ressembler si tu fais ces cinq c'est
prendre dragon s'ils font des cinq à des
trucs de Benoni si tu fais E5 le prend
des une sorte de philidat ou truc comme
ça le 5 des 5 plus un truc destinienne
tu peux jouer avec aucun de ces pions là
et faire des piercer avec B tu peux des
fois pousser des cinq pour pour
fragiliser le centre de cette manière là
et du coup ça va plus une tronche de
française donc très vite en fait là je
te parle de 50 ouvertures qui partent de
la même
vaut mieux avoir une petite expérience
du reste alors vu des parties et savoir
se débrouiller retomber sur ses pattes
donc donc voilà c'est pas trop une bonne
première ouverture je pense par contre
ah non clairement pas
mais sinon ça peut ça peut être ça
pourrait être convenir par exemple
oui mais parce que tu l'as jamais trop
étudié ou quoi mais je veux dire ça se
trouve tu es libre de mes skylenco tu es
très heureux quoi
ou pas mais bon par contre un débutant
donc pas du tout enfin moi je recommande
pas après peut-être d'autres commandes
je sais pas mais
mon avis c'est non
j'ai du mal à jouer donc
on va repartir dans la même truc bon bah
écoute
ils se font un match thématique ils s'en
foutent quand même bon il s'est un peu
changé il a fait un peu prendre des 5
qui avait pas fait dans l'autre partie
les jeux qui est BD plutôt
donc changement de structure
c'est trop compliqué tu vas te faire
mater en fait
les blancs vont attaquer le roi tu
sauras pas le défendre donc fais pas ça
pour commencer et en plus tu sauras pas
comment agencer tes pions pour avoir des
bonnes versions des ouvertures précitées
donc c'est ça le problème en fait
c'est compliqué tu laisses le centre
mais tu le laisses pas longtemps si tu
vas pousser le 5 tu vas pousser ses 5 tu
vas faire un coup tu as déjà le fou qui
regarde dessus donc c'est une autre
manière je vais pas le centre même mais
c'est trop compliqué enfin je fais U4 5
fait des trucs normaux au début si
justement tu es plutôt débutant quoi
pourquoi pas ouais parce qu'on dit trop
compliqué aussi tu vas bouger ta dame 50
fois tu vas te la faire enfermer enfin
ça va pas le faire quoi non je vous la
regarde si tu veux ou 4 5 c'est très
bien le 4 aussi
débutant tu peux prendre le mien
excellent livre pour pour débuter ah bah
oui
et après quand tu es un débutant avancé
tu as le deuxième
je pense largement jusqu'à 2000 ça va
je sais pas qui la même des gens à 2100
2002 qui l'ont lu ils ont dit qu'il
était bien aussi
bon
en blitz à ton avis c'est pas ça va
t'aider mais c'est
tu pourrais être 2000 en blitz sans
avoir rien lu quand être 1200 je sais
pas trop comment dire en fait
ouais ça va pas être suffisant et tu
auras pas un bon instantané
mais ça va être parfaire des trucs dans
certaines parties ça sera utile tu vas
reconnaître tu auras des conseils ça va
mûrir
[Musique]
truc bizarre avec les échecs des fois tu
travailles bien et tu as pas du tout des
fois tu es de la merde et tu progresses
cela dit vaut mieux ne pas faire que de
la merde normalement à long terme ça
vient marcher de travailler mais c'est
rarement linéaire quoi c'est un peu pour
les son escalier et des fois tu as des
plateaux puis tu le passes et ça a l'air
très facile d'un coup j'ai pris 200
points je sais pas pourquoi comment et
après tu vas rebloquer mais donc faut le
temps que ça m'ature que ce soit à qui
t'a pas un truc précisément qui c'est un
multitude de choses qui te font
progresser
bon le conseil le plus simple qu'on peut
donner c'est de modifier la taille de
l'échiquier
c'est pas mal hein
j'ai pas pensé je crois que j'ai fait un
blitz tout à l'heure j'ai absolument pas
pensé
tu vas tout de suite progresser en fait
c'est instantané
les pièces sont moins de distance tout
de suite
les pièces sont moins de distance elles
sont plus en forme
je vais une partie
tu as gagné
à combien
[Musique]
entre un mec qui a un drapeau je sais
pas ce que c'est
mais tu pourrais facilement être 27 50
28 sans forcer mais je pense tu peux
même viser les 29
viser la lune
ça fait longtemps que tu as pas vu sur
un title d'ailleurs non mais je les
joueurs
dans dans la base donc j'ai pas envie et
de jouer sans jouer mon répertoire ça me
fait chier aussi en fait donc
ça me saoule ça te ferme
en fait je veux dire si je joue le title
tout seul dans mon coin et que au pire
je suis ridicule je m'en fous ça va mais
de le faire en live tu as pas envie de
faire n'importe quoi tu étais un peu
devant les gens tu veux essayer de faire
un truc bien mais j'ai vraiment pas
envie de jouer le répertoire
parce que bon je veux pas ça va déjà je
travaille jamais si jamais je connais un
truc j'ai peut-être pas le montrer pour
jouer un blitz je m'en fous quoi et donc
j'ai un problème quoi tu vois
et donc de
[Musique]
ça me force à pas jouer avec l'ouverture
ce qui est un problème donc après bah
oui souvent je réfléchis je suis mal au
temps enfin
donc oui je peux pas briller quoi
si je le fais tout seul dans un coin
ça me regarde que moi quoi c'est pas
grave mais
oui mais enfin c'est déjà bien
le problème c'est que j'ai pas de
répertoire tout court donc si déjà je
dois créer un avertir à côté
en fait il est pas très dur sans
répertoire title on pourrait la prendre
c'est les gambida ou tu fais un A6 assez
tôt au hasard
et sur 4 c'est la Roser facile quoi
oui mais bon déjà pour jouer sur toutes
les antices siciliaires les fous Bessins
[Musique]
tout le temps et toi faut baiser qui va
savoir réagir
toujours pareil en fait c'est une
question
en fait
mais il a réussi à gagner une partie
en rapide contre Maxime Lagarde grâce au
title c'est une pré bataille
avec les Blancs
déjà il la joue bien en partie lente
enfin toutes les cadences c'est pas le
problème mais il a joué quand il était
petit
donc en fait
c'est comme des trucs qu'on joue contre
des petits qu'on joue plus mais en fait
à tous les réflexes tu connais en fait
tu étudié tu connais les machins donc là
en plus il a remis une dose avec la
théorie plus moderne donc même si c'est
qui je demande à deux cons il sait quand
même où vont les pièces et quoi faire ce
que tu peux genre moi je pourrais pas
faire parce qu'en fait je l'ai jamais
joué ce truc quasiment pas je l'ai fait
deux fois en partie lente ou quoi
donc ça en fait enfin vaut mieux jouer
un truc sans trop de théorie mais tu
connais à peu près où tu te places genre
toi tu préfères la scandinave mais tu
connais pas tu ça irait quoi
complètement
alors que si on t'envoie sur
complètement autre chose ce serait
vachement plus dur
et donc
il l'a eu petit il a rénové donc là il
va pas sortir ses vrais nouveautés de
partie lente j'imagine
et
[Musique]
donc bah oui pas mal
tu me fais jouer la pire que en la
catastrophe
c'est comme si moi là je veux plus de
pire pendant 15 ans et puis je reviens
cliquer des title
à mettre les pièces
après tu peux jouer à la Kalash
juste pour jouer sans jouer enfin juste
pour cliquer
pas des petites variantes à la con ouais
faudrait que j'étudie E5 ou des coups
débiles au troisième pour
les sortir quoi mais du coup faut faire
ça me force à travailler pour un truc où
j'ai pas envie de travailler enfin
moi j'aimerais bien jouer un peu la
liquide mais bon parfois oui
ça peut ressembler la structure ah c'est
pour ça que j'ai bien sûr toujours sûr
ils existent je suis pas sûr je pourrais
faire beaucoup mieux que ce qui existe
enfin je pourrais remettre des fois deux
trois trucs alors du jour mais la zone
pour écrire un livre c'est pas mal de
travail déjà il faut avoir quelque chose
à raconter et se sentir
que ce soit utile
sur la SSE
bah pourquoi pas mais je sais pas trop
quoi dire on est au fond du trou quoi
mais j'ai repensé en fait tu vois
c'était pourquoi je regarde les matchs
ou quoi mais en fait c'est un peu comme
si les seuls battle quoi
bah ouais c'est en fait
c'est pas pour la qualité des coûts mais
tu je vibre quoi enfin ça
ouais mais des fois toi ils font des
coups de merde il peut te faire un raté
face au gardien ça traque des maths ça
fait des pâtes ça donne des pièces en un
ou des fois ça fait des bonnes parties
ah tu sais jamais trop donc tu as la
surprise et puis tu es supporter quoi tu
as envie qu'on gagne quand même donc tu
vivre mais en fait c'est ça en fait je
me fais des sautes battles j'ai
l'impression c'est ça le truc
en vrai les sabattles on s'amuse
toujours
bah c'est ça
super mais bon
le match
après c'est vrai que les conseils du
coach dans le livre ils sont magnifiques
j'en lis à Baki de temps en temps pour
le faire progresser pendant le title
a besoin pour pour la prochaine partie
bon on a donc des fois ils sont bateau
un peu ces conseils de coach mais ils
sont pas vraiment faux quoi ils sont
beaux les conseils du coach ils sont
beaux bah qui en tout cas il apprécie
apprécie
ouais des fois j'ouvre et je donne un
conseil du coach
magnifique
j'ai lu une partie aujourd'hui celle de
du loup dans la bergerie
c'est très heureux
[Musique]
avec un fou et les pions de la même
couleur
bravo
j'ai peut-être lu à Baki celui-là
il a beaucoup aidé
il faut mettre de lagressivité la phrase
bateau qui passe dans tous les sports
mais qui fait pas de mal elle est bien
cette phrase
dans le bon sens mais même dans le
mauvais ouais ça marche
comme hier BO5 et 2 jours de suite non
c'est bo4 de jour de suite enfin c'est
bo8 et c'est deux fois quatre parties
voilà c'est assez égal de nouveau vous
voyez la jauge il se passe absolument
rien dans cette partie nouvelle fois
mais on se fait kiffer
muscle ton jeu Robert muscle ton jeu et
magnifique cette vidéo
mais il est pas il est pas tort
c'était tellement un bon entraîneur ou
pas mais en tout cas ça avait bien
marché
mais bon il était champion du monde quoi
donc ce que je te dise après il a arrêté
donc il est parti là-dessus il a fait
comme Fisher quoi champion du monde stop
ciao
et il a construit son groupe il a fait
des choix forts à l'époque pas prendre
Cantona prendre canto va prendre Ginola
enfin
ça a complètement payé mais il a il a eu
une vision que il devait créer un groupe
plus que des individualités des mecs qui
jouent les uns pour les autres
et puis on est solide derrière et puis
on verra
milieu de terrain
a pris un peu la continuité finalement
c'est ce qui essaie de proposer aussi
dans ces
il a complètement pris la continuité de
mes jacquets il a gagné notre deuxième
Coupe du Monde c'est ça donc bon
c'est pas toujours flamboyant dans le
jeu quoi mais bon écoute le but ça reste
de gagner enfin je cherchais pas juste
de faire des jugabonitos
mais du coup jacquage c'est pas le truc
c'est qu'il a vraiment été raillé et que
il a quand même pas enfin les malvécu
tout ça quoi l'équipe c'était très mal
comporté avec lui donc je comprends
aussi que j'ai dit bon allez j'ai gagné
j'arrête et je vous emmerde quoi
bravo
les dessins je crois qu'il est fan de
l'équilibre dans le jeu de foot dans le
foot alors une équipe équilibrée j'ai vu
pas mal interviews où il t'explique
c'est oui c'est important l'équipe metal
joueur à gauche que tu as le joueur à
droite je sais pas il voit ça comme un
sur le terrain quoi
mais
je comprends en fait
il y a une fois on était hyper
déséquilibré justement c'était à l'Euro
c'est pour ça que le manque de milieu de
terrain je pense que ça va lui faire
très mal à des gens
dans son approche même du foot c'était
non mais il va en mettre en fait
peut-être je sais pas il va devoir
mettre le Fofana de Monaco il va devoir
mettre comme un vinga ou quoi mais c'est
tendre enfin c'est ça peut bien jouer un
match c'est pas le problème ça mais
c'est une interview de Drogba qui pense
au car ma vinga c'est ça va être un des
gros au milieu de terrain à venir ah
mais il est bon il est tout jeune encore
en fait il a tellement percé tôt qu'on a
l'impression qu'il a peut-être 25 non
non je pense donc il est très très bien
mais
là il suit un peu au réel cette année
l'année dernière vous êtes très bonne
rentrée ou quoi là bon bah faut
confirmer il va le faire j'ai aucun
doute mais que là tu lui dis ouais dans
un mois tu le tollé de l'équipe de
France
il y a deux c'est une différence entre
les deux
au milieu de terrain c'est juste trop
beau bah tu vois mais ouais de toute
façon voilà pareil lui aussi il allait
jouer quoi qu'il en soit mais là en fait
ça devient le enfin si il y a plus de
chamely il y a plus rien qu'en fait il
est indispensable maintenant alors
normalement il devait intégrer monter en
puissance tu vois je le vois un peu
comme un je sais pas si on reprend
l'équipe la vie équipe comme tu vois
viral à l'époque en 98 je veux pas trop
en 2000 concept titulaire mais
il a pu avoir cette influence parce que
aussi il y avait les mecs comme des
champs pour l'appui autour les petits
etc c'était pas juste virera tout seul
et des tout jeune avec lui qui a encore
moins d'expérience
donc je pense tu as besoin quoi que le
gars comme ça qui va devenir ton pilier
ils sont un peu entourés au début dans
au moins une grosse compétition et puis
après prend le relais à partir de 2024
ou quoi tu auras peut-être plus les
autres mais lui il aura le vécu
l'expérience on est d'accord que Patrick
Vieira c'est peut-être le meilleur
milieu de terrain récupérateur qu'on a
eu de l'histoire du football français
non c'est au-dessus de Pogba non
[Musique]
après c'est compliqué je parle avec des
souvenirs émerveillés de jeunes il parle
de Claude mcélérer aussi [ __ ]
viens elle était relayeur par
récupérateur
attention ici à plus de fautes à partir
d'un moment
mais après oui mais qu'elle est très
fort bah quand tu es comme c'est une
arme aussi tu vois je peux pas dire si
l'un est meilleur que l'autre ou quoi
mais on est comme une équipe énorme je
pense que cette équipe là elle était
encore plus forte que celle
de
laquelle 80
tu avais tout le monde
mais on a rien dit en fait
bizarre
elle était incroyable équipe en fait
mais je pense sur le papier elle était
plus sur le papier elle était plus forte
cette équipe
tu avais envie en plus
qui était à maturation enfin c'était pas
le Henri de 98 qui était jeune quoi
justement c'était le Henri d'Arsenal qui
était
[Musique]
quand même pas mal
bon en tout cas
ils sont pas croisés
impressionnant on te bat le Brésil
l'Espagne le machin
qu'on a gagné en fait c'était au dessus
le parcours était fou mais après tu
tombes sur une très très grande équipe
d'Italie
mais c'est pas il réaliste je pense la
finale
ils ont gagné vraiment sur sur leur
qualité fondamentale quoi
mais tu avais quand même un de mes
joueurs préférés de mes meilleurs milieu
de terrain préféré de l'équipe d'Italie
de toute l'histoire avec Gatuso et
pierrelot
Pirlo c'était c'est beau c'était énorme
méga toujours c'était vraiment un de mes
joueurs préférés il y a tous aussi
c'était tellement au-dessus ma Milan a
tellement eu une belle équipe avec eux à
l'époque et 6h en plus tu vois
[Musique]
ça me faisait penser juste à me rappeler
le milieu de
des Pays-Bas
mais peut-être qu'on pensera la même
chose quand on en reparlera dans 15 ans
de oui en 2022
il y avait Mbappé non mais le truc
c'était c'était les meilleurs
récupérateurs qui étaient énormes parce
que tu vois tu imagines la France tu as
maqué les Vieira en face tu as toujours
Pirlo
c'est juste que le niveau de
c'est juste hallucinant en fait c'est du
TAS du comté Pogba mais dans toutes les
équipes en fait
mais même les Anglais c'était lampe
partent Gérard
qu'est-ce qu'il était fort Gérard c'est
un genre préféré de muretas
c'est tu peux te dire que ça va gagner à
ton rôle mais
non mais quand tu es pas bien c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas des clowns attention
c'est très très fort mais c'est juste de
dire en fait tu penses aux équipes de
cette Coupe du monde
en fait tu as des milieux de terrain de
fou furieux mais peut-être que les
attaquants un peu moins fort
Benzema en fait tu as les deux
meilleures attaques en du monde ouais
mais franchement le Brésil italien
Rivaldo Ronaldo Ronaldo neuf quoi
Ronaldinho
et en 2006 le Brésil tu avais caca aussi
ouais caca Adriano qui était ah il était
ouais qui est en pleine bourre ouais il
est passé à côté
c'est juste de la folie quoi
en 2006 mais tu avais tous les mecs
autour mais tu vois l'Italie aussi tu
avais des attaquants genre enfin genre
Luca Tony par exemple ok ok
inzagiste
enfin moi j'adorais évidemment j'étais
fan comme fan de la Squadra j'adorais
mais c'est quand même particulier
en fait ouais mais bon en fait tu sais
que c'est
tu t'en fous qu'il fasse rien quoi il
est pas là pour faire par contre celui
qui était vraiment bon c'était viré
ouais
regardez
je crois qu'il était complètement con
par contre c'est un problème
les interviews que je disais est
complètement débile je crois
mais les bonnes valeurs après je sais
pas trop
romain
non oui
le piège non
pour éviter
que ces 6 coup droit
on fait rempli boutique
après moi cette Coupe du Monde c'est
ouais tu connais mon point de vue dessus
de toute façon
j'aime bien le foot et puis bon j'aurais
pas grand chose à faire c'est possible
j'allume la télé pour regarder mais
sûrement pas tous les matchs non plus tu
regardes juste au hasard en fait c'est
là tu cliques quoi
allez on va faire ce qu'on peut mais pas
sûr qu'on puisse beaucoup t'aider mais
vas-y dis-nous
là c'est nul ou poussette blanche c'est
nul nul après
il a commencé on pouvait un peu sa
position
c'est toujours pas suffisant pour perdre
mais
je pense Benzema il va faire une grosse
Coupe du monde
je suis pas sûr j'aimerais bien pour lui
comme c'est un joueur que j'aime bien en
fait je pense pas mais
c'est juste je pense pas parce qu'en
fait il était un peu blessé ces temps-ci
là il revient il a rentré il a fait un
truc pas trop mal avec le Real dans le
dernier match le peu qu'il a joué mais
va falloir qu'il digère qui
sera motivé à fond bon
et que je sais pas avec le corps suit
aussi donc ça a demandé pas mal de trucs
du monde si vous savez le nom de DC
qu'on connaît les chantiers de 90 ouais
mais c'est pas la même époque non plus
du mag déjà bon j'ai pas assez stable
mais on vit pas dans la même époque tu
peux pas
je sais pas comment dire il y a plein de
choses dont on est plus conscient
aujourd'hui on n'était pas conscient il
y a il y a 25 ans en réalité sur plein
de sujets notamment le climat par
exemple
on était moins sensibilisés ou je sais
pas comment dire tu peux pas comparer
je pense que tu en penses Fab
et ouais ouais non mais évidemment mon
il est différent la confiance elle est
différente les choses qu'on sait
aujourd'hui elles sont aussi différentes
mais c'est quoi en fait du coup qui me
disait quoi en 90 ou je sais pas quoi je
sais pas combien de 98 les morts au
stade en France
et le monde a évolué tu peux pas
comparer en disant ah ouais machin bon
sinon je vais te prendre des trucs qu'on
a fait
100 ans plus tôt et puis
en 1940 on faisait oui bon c'était pas
tout à fait les mêmes les mêmes la même
voix
après le Yapi ailleurs ouais c'est
c'était pareil avant et c'est ça c'est
pas parce que c'était nul avant que il
faut continuer à être nul quoi
je voulais juste répondre
à la question sur le dragon
ouais donc le Kiji G4 dont tu parles
nulle part pour tout le chat pour le
celui qui nous a posé la question c'est
ça oui prend ceci tu peux prendre de dés
le truc symétrique et changer les dames
tu reprends des roquets c'est pas grave
ou alors si jamais tu as un problème
avec la vente tu peux juste ok ne pas
faire cacher G4 tu le gardes en réserve
pour le coup d'après et là si les blancs
te font un F3 ou quoi pour l'empêcher tu
as des 5 voilà j'espère que ça répondra
c'est beau quand même pour la
construction des pyramides il y avait
des milliers de morts aussi
non mais je sais pas quoi
problème là pour ce truc au 14 c'est
qu'il y a rien qui va quoi
c'est un peu tout moche dans la connerie
quoi on va dire
il y a pas grand chose qui va
travailler
les gens qui en sont morts pour le
climat pour organiser une coupe du monde
à ce moment-là de l'année pour enfin
tout ce que tu veux en fait sur tous les
sujets il y a un truc qui va pas quoi
donc
[Musique]
les avions toutes les 10 minutes pour
transporter les supporters alors il se
trouve que je connais quelqu'un qui
travaille à l'UEFA ou la FIFA je sais
plus
et d'après ce que je sais en fait
c'était en projet de déplacer les
supporters par avion et faire des petits
vols de 10 15 minutes pour les ramener à
leur hôtel
et du coup ils sont du club ça va pas le
faire on va pas pousser le boucher je
crois qu'il va pas faire autrement en
fait c'est juste que il y a pas assez de
place et enfin c'est pas prévu je crois
que c'est pas possible il est dans le
pays
dans les petits pays à l'étranger et
donc en fait ils ont juste pas le choix
ouais mais genre ça rajoute encore à la
débilité du truc non mais ça aurait
jamais dû avoir lieu quoi ils auraient
jamais dû avoir le projet et bon il y a
eu un bel article qui était sorti dessus
sur les dessous du truc
et on a notre petite part de
responsabilité en France
mais après ouais c'est ça le truc c'est
que
évidemment pas tout le monde il est tout
beau tout le monde enfin pas eux c'est
vraiment très grave et nous on est très
bien quoi c'est pas du tout comme ça bah
c'était collectif quoi le truc collectif
encore une drôle voilà la partie là elle
était
donc tu te dis je sais pas ça a été
ressorti
après ça on sait pas mais c'est ce qui
se dit en tout cas
non mais en fait le truc c'est en plus
moi je suis plutôt pour que la Coupe du
Monde s'organisait un peu sur différents
continents et dans différents pays je
suis content que genre 2010 sur
l'Afrique du Sud et c'est sympa quoi
mais moi j'ai adoré la coupe du Sud un
personnellement ça doit être dans des
pays de foot tu vois que tu fais un peu
au Brésil un peu Amérique du Sud un peu
Afrique un peu Europe évidemment tu es
bien et puis et puis il me fait un bon
en 2002 c'était Coré Japon déjà c'est un
peu bizarre de faire sur d'autres pays
je trouve mais bon ok et conditions déjà
c'était un peu compliqué c'était hyper
humide ou quoi enfin
que ça aille dans tous les continents ça
par contre c'est bien
tu dois peut-être quand même qu'il y a
des bonnes conditions de jeu quoi je
sais pas
mais peu importe en soit je suis
d'accord mais fais-le un endroit où
c'est possible de le faire et que
ça rentre pas à 12 millions de
contraintes de Brésil
mon accueil et puis peut-être qu'il va
faire craquer petit à petit ce qui est
aussi si il est chiant là il veut aller
verger ça donc tu dois l'empêcher
tu crois c'est bien passé avec les
normes il a tellement mal joué ça ce qui
va pas te ramener le F3 j'ai de H3
machin
[Musique]
après tu peux te barrer
mais comment il s'est retrouvé à force
de vouloir que faire nul sans rien faire
ouais il se fait de la peine c'est que
les stades ont pas forcément servir
après la Coupe du Monde aussi
généralement c'est aussi le l'occasion
de construire de l'infrastructures et
Machin etc comme la Coupe du monde de
rugby qui aura lieu en France Fab mieux
ça c'est cool je vais aller voir un
match
c'est pas un énorme match mais bon tu
vas voir quoi
et de voir Italie Namibie
ça peut être un match sympa oui non mais
je comprends bien tu vois c'est pas le
match de l'année mais c'est des équipes
qui ça va ouais ça je veux dire je vais
pas voir un truc le plus horrible au
monde j'aurais préféré bon choix mieux
mais ça va
en vrai ça va
de toute façon en fait c'est parti comme
des petits pains il y a plus de place en
fait et j'avais plus que quelques places
sur celui-là je me suis bah vas-y je
clique j'achète et voilà moi je vais
essayer d'utiliser
mon travail d'influenceur pour essayer
de choper des places sur un beau match
pour le moment j'ai aucune idée mais bon
je vais juste écrire en fait
je te dirai
mais voilà donc oui donc je serai très
content j'irai donc ce sera
Geoffroy-Guichard ce match là pour ça je
vais à côté quoi tu vas voir la Squadra
exactement
un peu à reprendre du poil de la bête
ils ont quelques beaux joueurs notamment
un joueur que j'adore qui joue
maintenant pour le Stade Toulousain
Angel kapoos
l'arrière arrière est italien là qui
avait mis un essai incroyable dans le
dernier match des six nations étaient
partis tout seul il avait je sais plus
quoi c'était contre le pays de Galles il
avait passé en revue toute l'équipe
galloise à lui tout seul il avait marqué
l'essai de la victoire et il fait des
ravages là à Toulouse il est
impressionnant
petit ailier de poche qui joue à
Grenoble avant en Pro D2 qui était
repéré qui a fait qui a fait les joies
de la Pro D2 à Grenoble et qui
maintenant a fait les joies du Stade
Toulousain en Top 14
mais c'est pour moi c'est un des plus
beaux joueurs du monde en ce moment CAP
ou autre bon évidemment tu as
du pont tamac etc tous les joueurs
français là la génération d'origine et
tout mais dans les joueurs non français
tu vois j'ai envie de dire on se capte
[Musique]
non c'est c'est magnifique en fait ce
qu'il fait mais il a pas un gabarit de
tu vois c'est un petit je dois faire un
mètre 70 maximum
soit des difficultés de solidité
dernièrement
ni moins solide que dans un temps
c'est pas vraiment cette partie des
échecs qu'on aime c'est tu fais rien tu
fais rien tu attends qu'une minute
chacun et tu cliques comme un comme un
con pour gagner en 200 coups mais bon
les échecs
game of the chasse game important
toujours parler anglais enfin dans les
commentaires
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible il
l'a raté
du coup on va avoir aussi
et on va avoir une pause un peu plus
courte femme
les poules il va pas en bouger de là
que la partie de Baki que j'ai mis en
rediffus j'ai mis une rediff et
incroyable quoi la partie la plus
chiante de l'année
dans une finale immonde
partie dure 7 minutes c'est de la merde
il se passe rien quoi
c'est beau quoi est-ce que les gens ont
cliqué en masse sur la vidéo c'est
vidéo très regardé c'est une partie de
merde
pensez une pause express
on revient dans 10 minutes
[Musique]
et voilà mon Fab on est de retour
et on peut on peut dire on peut dire
officiellement que tu seras à Cannes en
février mars
on s'occupait de l'hébergement à
l'instant on va le faire foison de vidéo
non pendant
on va faire un stock pour un an ou deux
vidéos tous les jours en fait ça va être
magnifique
ça va être sympa peut-être de la
fabinale peut-être
la fanital je sais pas
oui et on va avoir un petit peu la
petite aussi
en fait on fera aucune vidéo on sera
peut-être à fond avec la petite
vlogs
avec Micha en fait et puis on arrête
tout quoi enfin
ça va être sympa quand tu vas voir la
petite
est-ce que tu as un patient de voir la
petite ou pas bon j'imagine moins que
toi mais franchement ouais ça va me
faire plaisir pour vous et
de voir comment ça se passait etc
évidemment
ce que je vois que tu vois bon il y a la
petite bon tu vois il est bon il y a la
petite tu vois mais tiens il y a un truc
joli qui est G5 prend F7 qui a eu 6
gagne la dame
mais avant quand j'ai vu NAT elle est
très heureuse de la petite enfin elle a
dit oui je vais venir avec elle en
février
en février en fait
beaucoup plus que le match du
championnat du monde en fait
estimateur absolument rien à [ __ ] en
fait par contre je viens
j'espère qu'elle sera en pleine forme
oui mais je pense qu'on va envoyer aussi
un football manager sérieux avec la SSR
tu viens hein voilà ça parle
sérieusement non voilà je pense qu'on va
vraiment se faire un moment donné un
week-end ou je sais pas quoi on va
cliquer à fond quoi
mais ça et puis qu'on prépare notre
double quoi ouais ouais il va falloir
qu'on prépare le double aussi
je pense on va passer à deux très bons
moments on va être très heureux on va
aller manger au resto tous les jours du
rouvy du machin
il y a le Festival des Jeux à Cannes
aussi
que tu connais forcément puisqu'on a
fait le stage ensemble donc
on la rencontre ensemble et du coup tu
vas être heureux de le voir
nickel non
j'ai mon problème de Bundesliga quoi
ouais c'est dommage que j'ai j'étais à
deux doigts de chauffer mon père pour
jouer en double avec toi
après on peut
on peut jouer bon tant pis c'est pas
pour cette saison là le truc juste tu
vois préparer jouer ça donne trop des
adversaires aux troquets du coin jouer à
tourner et puis on va boire à l'oeil
toute l'année quoi on va bien est-ce que
mon père j'essaye de le motiver à la
criminer en retraite je me dis sur les
objectifs championnat de France de
belote avec femme
[Musique]
c'est juste que tu vas essayer de kick
pour être champion de France de belote
enfin j'étais si tu te fais chier c'est
un titre
avec Fab toute la journée tu joues aux
cartes en fait enfin c'est
on peut demander les cames si Fabio
troquer du camp ah bah oui je pense que
ça va cliquer
mais je crois que le Hive des fois ils
organisent des droits de belote ah
magnifique
on viendra enfin ça sert à rien de faire
le tournoi quoi enfin oui
vous payez quoi c'est tout
oui
longtemps là j'ai parlé avec des gars de
la fédération de bridge oui alors ils
m'ont dit oui le bridge beaucoup plus
complexe que la coinche il y a plus
d'annonces enfin bon oui il y a plus un
an oui mais bon
est-ce que l'annonce fait le moine
je suis quand même pas sûr quoi
en français de quoi enfin tu vois c'est
un moment donné
[Musique]
ce que j'ai compris enfin bon très
complexe ta femme qui va s'y mettre ça
va déménager
non je sais que c'est pas c'est pas mal
comme jeu mais bon la coinche c'est sous
c'est sous côté malheureusement
mais mon père en plus il joue pas mal tu
aurais pu faire un beau double
[Musique]
je sais pas si ça joue
internationalement la coinche non non
en fait ouais
il y a des petites différences dans les
règles mais il joue un truc hyper
similaire mais c'est tout mais tes
autres pays que c'est absolument pas
quoi ils sont complètement cons les
autres pays en fait mais genre déjà en
Espagne ils ont des jeux de cartes
complètement débiles avec des piments
des pièces d'or des autres couleurs
pareil c'est ce qui remplace le picker
qui a retraite quelque part mais
avec tes taureaux quoi
ils ont pas les mêmes cartes
quand on joue au tarot dans les tournois
c'est pas du tout en fait dans les
autres pays ils sont
ils sont à la ramasse sur les jeux de
cartes ouais en Russie ils jouent que à
des jeux de merde ça me saoule mais
belote ils connaissent pas du tout quoi
enfin non non et puis ils comprennent
même pas l'intérêt qu'on a nos autres
cartes en fait ah bah non mais en fait
ce qui est fou qui quand même enfin ce
qui est incroyable sur le fait qu'ils
comprennent pas c'est que nos jeux de
cartes sont enfin genre il y a pas de
Chauvigny ils sont réellement au dessus
en fait
ils sont réellement plus intérêts on a
vraiment des très beaux jeux de cartes
mais d'ailleurs ça jouait beaucoup aux
cartes en France au 17 18e siècle
voiture était un pays de cartes en fait
attends les cames je vais devoir
Nakam et les blancs on est d'accord oui
donc ça va inverser pour la prochaine
partie
do you do
c'est Sarine Guéret on attend en fait le
début de maca parce que c'est un départ
décalé
c'est un peu comme les contre-la-montre
autour de France ils partent en même
temps il y a des parts et puis petit à
petit
alors après est-ce que Naka il sauve
vont rattraper Sarine et guéri parti
avant ça
c'est tout l'enjeu de cette quatrième
monde en fait
mais non on fera plein de vidéos quand
tu viens on fera plein de vidéos
on aura plus le temps parce que on est
toujours dans le rush avec des trucs de
con à faire des tournois comment et tout
là on sera tranquille
on ne vous montre rien on pourra se
poser
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est un peu la période tu vois
je sais pas je crois que les tournois je
sais pas ce que vous vous en pensez mais
il y en a il y a trop eu de mauvais
tournoi et je crois que je sais pas si
c'est moi qui fait une overdose aussi
c'est vraiment
après les audiences parlent
d'elles-mêmes aussi mais tu peux suivre
enfin je sais pas combien je sais pas
peut-être ça marche pas mais
un peu la première ronde machin tu vois
bon il nous soul vas-y il y en a marre
ou le tournoi intéressant ou tu attends
un peu puis ça s'anime et puis à deux
trois rondes de la fin ça joue la gagne
ou machin tu peux dire allez vas-y on
revient voir mais pas t'embêter à
regarder 8 heures par jour un truc ainsi
pide à soi quoi
mais je sais pas
est-ce que ça c'est une option ou c'est
quoi ton débile normalement c'est tout
le problème c'est que c'est souvent
que les gens là les tournois ça
j'aime bien toujours on discute on est
bien ouais non mais c'est ça mais c'est
plus l'occasion de discuter mais du coup
tu vas pas faire ça 6 heures par jour
pendant les 14 jours de vagues c'est
trop
dire que les les tendances en soi ça
intéresse plus mais parce que aussi
enfin c'est quand même deux ans qu'on
regarde des tournois où il y a pas de
choses
façon ils ont jamais vraiment réussi à
faire une saison tu vois même là le bon
suivra sera sympa il y aura l'équipe de
France mais en soi
ouais mais pourquoi en fait c'est
vraiment pas une bonne compétition en
fait c'est à cause des organisateurs en
soi sur le papier c'est bien
non mais en fait de vouloir faire un
truc comme ça pourquoi pas mais ça c'est
décidé
au dernier moment mais c'est ça j'ai un
truc suivant
et aucune équipe n'envoie l'équipe type
va c'est-à-dire qu'en fait c'est pas
pris au sérieux par personne donc à la
fin ils vont te laisser dans un titre
mais enfin tu as un titre parce que
parce qu'on vient de le donner parce que
personne jouait bah c'est comme s'il y
avait une Coupe Davis et qu'en fait tu
avais aucun joueur du top 15 mondial que
enfin ouais où tu en as un ou deux qui
viennent comme ça par hasard mais en
fait
[Musique]
et encore la France on est ceux qui
envoient relativement la plus grosse
équipe possible exactement
la France va la jouer assez sérieux
alors on a parlé des cartes espagnoles
il y a les quatre couleurs c'est les
coupes donc il y a des coupes à boire
c'est pas des coups pour couper
les deniers donc c'est les pièces les
bâtons c'est ça et les épées mais les
bâtons c'est un peu des piments c'est ça
que je peux
voilà donc
c'est exactement le même truc bon sauf
c'est une italienne mais ça va
ressembler très portrait à ce qu'on a vu
jusqu'à présent est-ce qu'on va suivre
le speechasse ben bizarrement dans le
speechestre ça reste de toutes les
compétitions internet celles que je
préfère
j'avais bien aimé la première édition
derrière tout le monde avait aimé après
petit à petit like et quand même retombé
sur cette compète pour
multaraison on va dire que c'est la de
toutes les compétitions existantes sur
Internet c'est la seule où il y a des
matchs ça me fait vraiment plaisir de
les voir
tu vois l'an dernier
[Musique]
parce que c'était de 1h à 4h du mat mais
moi il se trouve que je dormais pas et
j'ai carrément regardé la fin parce que
il y avait un point d'écart que c'était
chaud donc fait ok tu vois pour que je
regarde une compétition d'échec quand je
commande pas enfin faut plus à 4h du mat
quoi encore plus à 4h du matin mais là
je te jure je vais me coucher à minuit
3h20 et je regarde il y a d'ink qui mène
d'un point puis c'est chaud puis les
parties sont cool je me suis regardé je
me suis retrouvé à regarder
pour que je me retrouve à regarder un
truc d'échec c'est
le match de Maxime il était sympa la
finale contre so c'était aussi sympa
même si ce soit pas réussi à mettre en
danger fin non mais c'est
très très franchement de tous les trucs
internet c'est le c'est le meilleur et
c'est tellement dommage que ils avaient
pas pris ce speech qui est bien et
qu'ils aient mis les 1000000 de dollars
tu as un truc qui est peut être pas mal
machin et tout et c'est bizarre d'avoir
pris un autre format c'est con en fait
non en plus le speech si jamais tu veux
vraiment faire comme là leur truc à
Toronto quoi tu le fais ensuite mais
c'est vrai tu es mille fois mieux
c'est à dire que tu fais les phases
machin et puis peut-être tu dis ok les
quatre derniers vas-y on se fait le
weekend final on va à Toronto ou tu veux
en fait Toronto ou pas
comme ça tu fais le truc et puis un
match et puis l'autre après j'ai fait en
même temps évidemment et la grande
finale le dimanche et puis c'est bon
c'est fini non mais moi j'aurais fait
j'aurais fait encore différemment enfin
dans la même idée que toi mais peut-être
encore mieux je les aurais pris
peut-être même sur deux weekends
tellement il y a d'argent tu peux leur
dire de rester et en fait j'en aurais
fait jouer aucun sur Internet c'est en
fait tu étais tout sur invitation tant
pis en fait enfin c'est pas grave et tu
joues tout en réel et je te mets pas
d'invité enfin je te mets pas de
qualification sur internet en fait là ah
tiens c'est pas de chance en fait mais
tu pourras pas en fait
et au moins j'ai un fil de Clean je te
prends les lots en blitz enfin je sais
pas je te fais un mélange et je te fais
ça mais enfin je récupère un peu ce que
tu disais quoi mais juge enlève la face
calife internet je m'en fous
sur les 16 mais en fait pas plus enfin
c'est c'est pas les 8 en fait non non
bien sûr mais tu comprends zéro enfin
ou tu organises le week-end encore avant
ce qui veulent ils viennent sur place et
ils font quoi oui alors ça je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec toi
où tu trouves
mais c'est facile en plus dans chaque
pays un Bary sport partenaire
alors les Français ils vont aller spot à
Paris par exemple
il serait prêt à l'organiser on pourrait
carrément commenter sur place et puis ta
Maxime qui joue à qui joue puis je joue
de la fin ouais je suis d'accord avec
toi chaque pays trouve un truc et on va
se voir s'ils veulent et puis voilà et
puis de toute façon si tu devais c'est
pas même les joueurs en quelque sorte
ils ont des agents à ce niveau-là ils
peuvent se démerder enfin je sais pas
c'est quand même 200000 dollars pour
gagner 3 matchs bon un moment donné même
s'il faut que tu payes 500 € en arbitre
bon bah tu te débrouilles tu as des
millions enfin
les prix sont démentiel plus largement
bien arriver faire deux trois frais à
côté pour que ce soit bien mais
t'imagines comment ce serait bien
c'est étonnant en fait qu'ils aient pas
fait ça parce qu'ils tiennent un format
qui est pas mal que les gens aiment bien
les joueurs aiment bien et même tu vois
j'en discuter avec Richard et tout de
suite et ça reste un truc que les gens
aiment bien quand même ce speech
étonnamment dans les compétitions
internet c'est un peu la dernière qui
garde un petit prestigeonner tu vois
c'est un peu le Grand Slam d'internet je
sais pas comment dire
c'est beau en fait
à tous les tons internet qui sont là qui
sont venus bon ils mettent des millions
de tout bon oui bon bravo enfin tu as
gagné bon on s'en fout et là le
speechers ah non en fait ah tiens c'est
un truc un peu historique quoi il y a
une il y a il y a un prestige
qui s'est fait au cours des saisons et
c'est dommage de pas avoir mis le paquet
sur ce truc là qui est bien
extrêmement étonnant Fabien ils l'ont
pas empiré mais ils l'ont pas amélioré
ils ont pas mis de plus de moyens aux
trucs qui plaisaient c'est ça qui est
dommage tu as voulu faire des trucs à
côté et mettre le paquet sur un truc bah
tu sais que ça marche tu sais que les
gens aiment tu sais que c'est cool et tu
sais que ça rend un peu de un petit
respect des pères quoi entre guillemets
je sais pas si vous vous aimez bien les
speechers mais moi je suis content en
tout cas de les commenter cette année
même si je vais peut-être raté un ou
deux matchs malheureusement
j'ai fait quelques matchs Roland dernier
même pendant que j'étais Lyon non ouais
ouais c'était cool
non mais après juste il faut qu'il
modifie un truc ou deux c'est quand il y
a un carnage dans le match qui s'arrête
vous qui fasse un système de 7 ou que
lui mais c'est juste ça c'est pas grand
chose en fait c'est très facile à gérer
ça mais tu as pas envie de voir un 25 un
encore une fois ou moi un truc pas mal
je leur avais dit de enfin c'était con
comme idée mais j'avais proposé à la
chaise comme évidemment ça a été refusé
parce que ça pouvait changer les temps
d'audience pour les pubs bon attention
j'ai dit en fait à tout moment dans le
match tu mets 6-0 ou 5-0 bon à décider
c'est un KO et tu as gagné
non en fait je disais ok au fait même si
tu es mené 8 à 1
bon en fait le match
c'est un KO tu as gagné le match
bon c'est très improbable à un moment
donné même si tu arrives au bu en
belette avec 10 points de moins tu en
gagnes deux dafiler bon de l'autre
comment ça suit un peu
c'est un petit ajout complètement débile
mais
ça permet
ils peuvent refuser ou quoi mais oui en
fait c'est ça leur problème il veut
absolument avoir le temps de match mais
c'est pas des échecs ça en fait c'est
juste pas le format pour des échecs ils
ont essayé de faire au tennis exactement
la même chose c'est pour les annonceurs
en fait et j'ai lu il y a il y a un
compte de tennis qui est très
intéressant qui a parlé de ça qui disait
qu'en fait tu as plus les publicitaires
préfèrent les sports où tu sais combien
de temps ça dure pour plein de raisons
parce que pour eux c'est plus pratique
et c'est pour ça que le tennis dans un
monde ils ont tenté circuit qui a pas du
tout marché où les 7 ça se jouait en
temps je sais pas si tu te rappelles oui
oui mais le truc qui oui ils avaient
fait un truc en Inde ou je sais pas quoi
ouais et aux États-Unis et genre un 7
durée je sais plus 10 minutes et tu te
renvoyer la balle et ça avait pas du
tout marché ils ont été obligés de
garder le système qui marche parce que
c'était complètement intéressant donc on
est un mec mais bon bah dit 5 oui bon tu
continues à jouer tu sais pourquoi en
fait c'est pas du tout en fait
et c'est pas des échecs de bouger un fou
dans une nouvelle opposée à jouer la
montre et c'est tout en fait
je comprends soit mieux pour les
annonceurs ça j'ai bien compris mais en
fait avec un autre sport un autre jeu
non mais en fait c'est mieux
pour eux mais tu as 10 fois moins de
personnes qui regardent donc au final
c'est le problème ça a été le premier
tennis c'est qu'en fait c'est mieux et
moins bien à la fois
c'est qu'il vaut mieux avoir de
l'audience et des gens qui regardent qui
un truc enfin c'est non mais en fait
les gens regardent et que ça un temps
très clair mais non en fait tant pis tu
mets un ça se joue en point c'est tout
ça c'est plus que ça frère l'histoire
attend fixe et à audience équivalente
mais en fait ça te fait perdre
l'audience ça devient complètement con
donc au tennis ils sont revenus sur ça
et c'est c'est assez évident mais tout
ça pour dire quoi tout ça pour que ouais
ce speech ça reste quand même de toutes
les compétitions internet c'est la seule
où je me dis quand même ah bah tiens il
y aura quelques petites soirées
sympatoches quand même tu vois un
acading bon je suis content de le revoir
non je suis pas dessus quoi ouais tu
craches pas dessus tu vois tu regardes
tu dis ah ouais c'est sympa
en plus sur un mâle nous c'est toujours
sympa de voir ma douche quand même
bons
si les spécialistes d'Internet ont un
peu plus de mal à être spécialiste tu
vois
si la spécialité internet tu vois elle
se voit un petit peu moins sur un format
speech
après toi tu auras quand même tu auras
quand même quelques spécialistes tension
qui joue cette année je crois pas
3e mondial Aniche André King non mais
tu vois pourquoi tu as pas écrit tu CLA
en fait peut-être qu'il a refusé mais
pour moi c'est dommage je pense pas
qu'il a refusé
non mais bon ok enfin le mec il est 3
fois champion du monde enfin ok est-ce
que tu as plus envie de voir gris Chuck
ou Gary en fait
[Musique]
si tu regardes la liste il manque que
Grisha non mais après je sais pas c'est
dommage qu'il y avait que maintenant on
n'est jamais joué ce truc juste pour
voir tout ce qui est vraiment pas les
accessoires j'en sais rien mais
ça peut avoir de la gueule un petit ange
au milieu tu joues comme ça quoi
puis bon j'ai pas de Douda
après ils ont plutôt les deux choix
ou pas
c'est juste que nous on a aussi le côté
non mais on aime bien mais qui parle
mais bon il a trouvé du monde donc il
est légitime mais en plus il les jouets
bien mais les situations
il fait des très beaux matchs
après peut-être ah tu sais pourquoi il
joue pas ah je sais pourquoi il joue pas
non justement est-ce que ça tombe
pendant les candidates
faut garder les petites et puis à mon
avis s'il y a du travail de prépa à
faire ou quoi ok non mais gris chou qui
datent je lui demander je peux pas je
peux lui écrire sur WhatsApp
mais je pense que c'est pour ça
bon après ok pas mal de ça pourquoi pas
en fait
je suis content mais juste en fait Erika
ici ça arrive enfin c'est trop en fait
enfin tu as déjà goût cache à d'où ça
t'auras en jeune c'est sur les deux plus
fort ok mais ça ring il est combien
mondial
en fait
il est légitime ce qui est champion du
monde de rapides
qui est légitime parce qu'il est top
mondial il monte à fond
et après
je veux bien que tu en prennes un sur
deux mais en fait c'est juste parce que
les Indiens font de l'audience et que tu
veux 40 millions d'Indiens ou bah il y a
des chances
non mais tu vois enfin je suis pas
contre
parce que c'est vrai que tu as sûrement
d'autres joueurs dans les 72 meilleurs
mondiaux qui peuvent postuler
voilà du coup très clairement après il a
peut-être refusé on sait pas tu as les
cours
[Musique]
tu peux avoir du bof par exemple
pourquoi pas tu peux toujours avoir
Artémis toujours le fameux qui n'est
jamais pris de part mais je crois qu'il
a juste le jeu en fait
pour avoir des hacks en fait
oui bon non mais
genre moi je veux pas le voir mais en
fait quand même plus fort que ça j'y
peux rien c'est en fait même lui déjà
j'ai pas envie de le voir
si tu es américain que les Américains tu
peux avoir Robson
c'est pas mal en fait mais
il a déjà oui ou même un arrondiki je
vais prendre un commentateur enfin en
mode enfin troll non en mode genre while
cards
c'est amusant pour les gens en fait il
est nul un autre type c'est pas mal moi
après évidemment si je la controverse si
on veut mais c'est caryakim quoi
il aura probablement fait ça par de
suspension ouais c'est sûr qu'elle sera
terminée
je veux dire
après ce qui aurait été beau c'est de
prendre neiman
et on discute du speech il sera une
super compétition à suivre 0 troll
absolument 0 troll on a
une bonne position pour Wesley le chat
oui
bah là il avait envoyé
[Musique]
dessus et au moins les blancs faut pas
prendre de gel en l'air mais tout
reprend et ta page est 5 parce que Kylie
F5 attaque la dame et tu fais des trous
partout et du coup il va s'ouvrir la
colonel doubler les tours etc
c'est peut-être un hasard qui est autant
d'indien non mais c'est peut-être un
hasard mais c'est juste je veux dire par
là que tu as des joueurs sur les mêmes
Erika ici enfin si tu veux prendre
Sarine parce qu'il a beaucoup de vélo
sur chaise comme pourquoi pas mais du
coup Erika ici il y a quand même
plusieurs gars qui sont devant notamment
du rapport
en fait même dominez là bon
tu peux prendre je peux prendre mes
diarrafes tu prends plein de gens en
fait
et comme je dis ah non c'est un nom
quand même après peut-être c'est lui qui
refuse avec Rami
il veut pas jouer cramique
ouais bon il est encore actif mais oui
je pense qu'il refuse en fait je n'ai
pas d'idée parce qu'il a jamais fait ces
trucs pas trop le brancher mais
ça non en fait
très bon état donc
[Musique]
ça pourrait être intéressant de le voir
à l'oeuvre juste peut-être que justement
il glitch jamais sur internet que il est
pas bien avec une soirée dans les doigts
qui va pas avec cliquer vite et que bon
ben ça emmerde de se faire flaguer quoi
donc il veut pas il va bien me jouer au
bras échecs sur un échiquier mais ok
mais sinon en soi
ce sera intéressant
mais bon du coup elle est le temps il
est bien aussi parce que tu as des beaux
joueurs enfin je veux dire t'imagines à
ce tour là c'est complètement différent
si tu as Carlsen si tu as Ding si tu as
une époque enfin ça aurait une autre
saveur aussi c'est aussi le line-up qui
fait qui fait beaucoup
[Musique]
le format aussi mais pas là tu vois le
format Facebook mais
d'abord
on s'en fiche en fait
on va pas regarder gars tu fais genre je
sais pas la coupe du monde de foot elle
est bien parce qu'il y a des bonnes
équipes tu me mets le Qatar qui va jouer
contre l'Iran et la Corée l'Australie
enfin je m'en fous quoi
mais en fait c'est pas si clair parce
que si on prend il veut pas qu'il prend
des quatre il touche là quand même bah
si il veut ça et puis on prend
du pion F4 et ok parce qu'en fait sur
tout reprendre
il repart vers eux
c'est pas mal son cou en fait aussi
avoir
genre FG qui est des 4
j'ai HH je pense ouais
complètement par hasard avec Mathieu un
truc un peu similaire
dans une vidéo qu'on faisait et il se
trouve qu'on en avait conclu bah c'est
avec deux tours contre deux tours
cavaliers et cette structure enfin
c'était pas la même truc à une dame
c'est les trois pions et on en avait
conclu que c'était égal
en fait les trois pions sont aussi fort
que le cavalier alors après c'était pas
la même structure à la dame et puis ça
joue sur des détails
mais c'était une partie un peu bizarre
qu'on avait regardé et comme il y avait
une nouveauté théorique Mathieu avait
poussé à fond et en fait
tu avais un truc comme juste c'est
similaire sauf que tu as les pions je
sais pas à cette B7 C6 c'est A4 B2A C2
enfin je sais pas exactement mais juste
les pions qui ont pas trop bouger Elda
mais il se trouve que en fait du
cavalier trouve pas vraiment des cases
et puis on avance c'est vraiment double
tranchant
comment je fais en brigader là dans mais
en fait des fois je fais en brigader
dans les vidéos avec Mathieu parce que
c'est terrible si on fait les vidéos le
matin bon évidemment bon pour la théorie
le machin et tout je m'en fous en fait
je m'en fous complètement mais Mathieu
en fait il a analysé comme un fou parce
qu'il met ses bases de données à jour il
veut absolument montrer ça c'est
terrible en fait il veut absolument oui
bon je te montre c'est pour toi oui mais
en fait non enfin si c'est pour moi
juste enfin tant pis c'est pas grave en
fait c'est moi je m'en fous un peu en
fait mais il me montre à fond alors
après ça me sert donc du coup il doit se
dire j'ai vraiment bien fait de lui
montrer vraiment très utile mais tu vois
il a pas ouais mais il fallait en plus
je pense qu'on en parle dans la vidéo de
la variante Naka n'a jamais su en fait
ouais mais faut travailler avec Mathieu
mais la vidéo c'est sur une partie forêt
de demander à Mathieu je pense que vous
pouvez retrouver cette analyse c'est une
partie chaque fois j'ai du double en
tête mais du coup ça va être une partie
de Carlsen c'est une prépa de quelqu'un
et c'est une italienne ou une espagnole
variante bizarre et à cette finale là
quelque part
si quelqu'un arrête
ça dit quelque chose ouais mais c'est ça
il se trouve que ça et que c'est dans la
prépa et que c'est égal
ils vendent forest c'est un mec proche
de Carlson je suis coalition
vente forest ça doit être vaïkenzee
ça va être une partie de vente forest ça
va et 2022 bon vous pouvez retrouver la
vidéo on analysa et on parle exactement
de cette structure donc j'ai toujours su
en fait
c'est cool de garder une bonne mémoire
quoi
je me rappelle le quasiment rien après
mais je me rappelle que j'allais me
rappelle jamais des coups précis je me
rappelle que des concepts
précis j'arrive pas c'est pour ça que
j'arrive pas à les ouvertures mais après
si tu montres un truc stratégique ou
quoi je me rappelle
c'est pour ça que j'arrive bien dans les
finales comme c'est un peu plus concept
j'ai une meilleure mémoire conceptuelle
que brute du coup du coup pour le coup
quoi
parce que bon on va sur le nombre de
vidéos que je fais souvent je suis en
train de ce que j'ai raconté avec ces
dans l'espagnol avec le sacrifice du
pion des cinq connu mais je m'appelle
plus du nom exactement c'est un truc
sacrifice de pion machin t'attaque enfin
ça doit être ça enfin bon peu importe
mais bon il se trouve que voilà pour que
tu saches Fab ce rapport matériel là
c'est censé être égal
bon c'est beau quoi je t'ai appris
quelque chose
donc genre Scipion compte 3 avec une
aile des garni
donc tu as le droit un peu à poil mais
c'est ça
j'imagine faut pas se faire bloquer mais
en fait au final pourquoi pas mais avant
non je pense qu'il avait gagné avec les
Noirs en fait d'ailleurs
deux tours cavaliers contre deux tours
et
ça change des trucs
en force
mais il va peut-être pas gagner d'accord
en fait ce match on rigole on rigole
mais là il est pas très bien quand même
enfin il a juste une qualité de moi
[Musique]
quand même
le chat en pleine forme
à 6
c'est pas loin
mais dans l'autre partie ça joue encore
par curiosité
S
5 et 7 tu bloques
allez c'est pas simple en fait ce que
maman il y a fkf1
j'ai compris mais trop tard aussi je me
serais fait avoir il va tomber
comme on a dit arnaque c'est bien ce
qu'on avait dit au début de ce match Fab
OK et juste tu peux revenir enfin pour
nous curiosité à nous quoi du coup ce
qu'il fallait faire pour gagner
ou pour
c'était pas ça
[Musique]
voilà
et juste avant
et là tu progresses comment enfin je
comprends que tu es gagnant mais voilà
[Musique]
beaucoup trop dur
avec si peu de temps tu sais que c'est
gagnant mais enfin tu soupçonne mais
là c'est pas sûr qu'il a gagné ça
non c'est pas sûr du tout si ce mec
intéressant avec le cavalier placé comme
ça qui te bloque bien
il va peut-être même la perdre en fait
bon ça je vais peut-être pas jusque-là
c'est pas facile en fait de passer le
blocus
non pas du tout
la finale
en fait
il va même jouer le gain
différence tu dois pas prendre non
il va essayer de te répéter les coups
[Musique]
plus avec les Blancs je déteste ces
trucs là ça me rend partout
tu as pas de prix sur la position en
plus
c'est un truc gluant quoi ça te glisse
entre les mains c'est horrible
mais bon après comme ça que je suis
toujours par perdre en fait je m'énerve
et on va faire un truc comme toi
et je vais pouvoir tatouer là-bas qui
m'emmerde
en plus j'aurais tellement énervé vous
avez c'est pas possible il fait une cale
machin il a rien vu il sera
non mais c'est pas drôle en fait tu sois
pas facile
trois pions c'est qui le plus fort le
titre de la vidéo c'était guéri et la
partie tu vois et bien russe
il y a personne pour le coup
tu vois ça fait une autre association
ça me rendrait fou avec les Blancs là ça
ça me rendrait fou
je pète un câble
je vais être tellement énervé
ouais c'est très dur je sais pas si tu
es mieux
et que il pense que les blancs sont
mieux mais enfin je pense pas lui il
pense ouais
c'est dégueulasse en fait [ __ ]
non mais tire des fois c'est dégueulasse
en plus
ouais
c'est horrible c'est horrible j'aurais
tellement
hâte de toussoir
c'est pas de la chance c'est provoquer
mais genre en fait c'est c'est un défaut
du jeu en fait non mais le truc c'est
quand il se prend F4 et tout ça il est
juste mal
mais ça doit pas tourner fin c'est pas
normal que ce soit la résultante de ce
truc là ce sont un truc si complexe
[Musique]
c'est pas possible
ikaro
tu prends de fines
je pense tu dois prendre en fait
tranquille
de sa partie ou dégoûté de pas avoir pu
gagner parce qu'il avait sentir qu'il
était pas loin quoi ah bah oui
franchement
ça terrible dans tous les matchs
de voir un petit Armageddon à nouveau
en vrai les parties étaient plus sympa
aujourd'hui oui
c'est plus serré c'est plus c'est plus
en jouet
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as envie de
me revoir demain
tu changerais un peu le film tu mettras
un peu de Carlson un peu de machin un
peu truc change un peu la carte enfin tu
fais deux trois machins et ouais ça
pourrait ouais
c'est pas loin en fait mais ouais
un peu plus de rythme un peu plus de
machin et ça pourrait
pour avoir un truc vraiment sympa à la
fin de partie par exemple c'était cool
non mais par contre pour le coup
il est très dur à battre quoi
c'est pour ça que même quand il fait le
4 c'est 6 c'est 4 D5 puis on prend un
champion c'est hyper concentré
j'ai une dame de plus mais tu vas voir
que
merci à toi mon Fab on se retrouve
demain on va dire